SPEAKER_00: Hello and welcome to Sparks of
the Past. We are now in Game 3. Last
SPEAKER_00: game, we had a bunch of people
who have now gone to the warehouse and
SPEAKER_00: started getting things
prepared. But Maru realized that she needed to
SPEAKER_00: charge her batteries as she
was particularly active in her combat. She
SPEAKER_00: only has A three-day kind of
activity charge. If she has a little bit
SPEAKER_00: lower activity, she probably
can get a little bit more. And they
SPEAKER_00: remember that they only have
three days on the Identity Veils entirely,
SPEAKER_00: so that was the second day,
and today is going to be the third day. A
SPEAKER_00: group of people went to the
Hall of Future Choices, and they saw a
SPEAKER_00: Social Solidarity team denying
a SoulSec team from doing the
SPEAKER_00: investigation. Emma also
realized that there was an expector, Marc
SPEAKER_00: Valois, who was a sole second
spectator that she knew,
SPEAKER_00: part of genetic crime and
alien biology, and that him being there seems
SPEAKER_00: unlikely that he was just
there for the assassination group. The team
SPEAKER_00: was able to get inside and
extract a mobile data tube that
SPEAKER_00: Dr. Luke Moreau put into the
toilet. And this data said that Mercer
SPEAKER_00: was killed for information
that was passed on to him, and that
SPEAKER_00: information was decoded in the
player's half. Sashi
SPEAKER_00: recharges from a police mech
during a public shaming in the Grand Axis,
SPEAKER_00: and the other members of the
team go and buy survival gear, they create
SPEAKER_00: modified burner
communications, and they meet Lucian, a data broker.
SPEAKER_00: Lucian trades them a... Two
trikes
SPEAKER_00: and future goodwill in
exchange for doing a daylight delivery from the
SPEAKER_00: farms to the basically vice
president, Chief Helene
SPEAKER_00: Marchand, secured residence.
The package they find out at the very end
SPEAKER_00: contains a corgi. When they
get back to the warehouse and break down
SPEAKER_00: all the codes to get the data
from the Modal Dale Tube, they realize
SPEAKER_00: that the data that the
original person who was assassinated seems to be
SPEAKER_00: talking about is that the
genetic matching of
SPEAKER_00: Jardin may have found a way to
create psykers. And that
SPEAKER_00: this experiment started about
40 years ago. But the nature of the
SPEAKER_00: psykers that are created are
also not necessarily clean
SPEAKER_00: humanoid Soleimani DNA. So you
might
SPEAKER_00: be corrupting the people by
making these psykers. There might be other
SPEAKER_00: things involved. There's a lot
of kind of little hidden details and
SPEAKER_00: notes in the document that
they have. Is there anything
SPEAKER_00: that someone would like to add
that I have forgotten? Was it two
SPEAKER_00: trikes or one? I thought it
was just one. Yeah, maybe just
SPEAKER_00: one trike. Yeah, because we
had to even have other people hang on. So I
SPEAKER_00: think it is just one trike. I
think you are correct. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: And, yeah. So, big issues that
are going to be coming up today is at the
SPEAKER_00: end of the night tonight, as
everyone wakes up, the veils will no longer
SPEAKER_00: work. You also have the same
information of
SPEAKER_00: you can communicate with the
Dolphin, you can start working on your new
SPEAKER_00: relationship with Lucian, you
could try to speak to the SolSec
SPEAKER_00: investigator that seems to
know some information about it. You still
SPEAKER_00: have the original assassinated
guys, Senator
SPEAKER_00: Mercer's, basically his iPad,
But it only has a certain amount of
SPEAKER_00: attempts to log into it. You
also were thinking about
SPEAKER_00: having Lucian get you guys
ammunition, and you've prepaid for some of
SPEAKER_00: it, but you have to pick it up
at the Transar section exchange. Those
SPEAKER_00: are a few things to kind of
throw out, but if anyone has anything they
SPEAKER_00: would also like to do, they
can feel free. Anyone have a
SPEAKER_00: burning need, or would you
like to pick from the crowd?
SPEAKER_01: I think we should talk it
over, have a group discussion. Perfect. Would
SPEAKER_01: you like to start the
discussion, Josh? I didn't, but I will.
SPEAKER_03: I didn't think my character is
that guy, but sure. So, yeah, what are we
SPEAKER_03: going to do? So, I guess the
question is, are we going to
SPEAKER_03: be pushing for... I guess we
need to have short-term and long-term
SPEAKER_03: goals. And I feel like, you
know, there's a lot of us,
SPEAKER_03: but having a direction would
be helpful. And perhaps we should agree.
SPEAKER_03: You know, are we trying to
find the information and exonerate ourselves?
SPEAKER_03: Like, is that a long-term
goal? Is that a short-term goal? Are we trying
SPEAKER_03: to get into SoulSec and see
what they know? You know, I think...
SPEAKER_03: Are we just trying to lay low?
At that point, maybe we should prioritize
SPEAKER_03: disguises because that seems
like perhaps a pretty
SPEAKER_01: good short-term goal. What do
people think?
SPEAKER_01: I mean, obviously,
SPEAKER_02: I think that exonerating
ourselves is – Does Emma know stuff
SPEAKER_02: about SoulSec?
SPEAKER_01: I know a couple things.
SPEAKER_02: I don't know, GM, do I know,
do I feel like I have an inside person?
SPEAKER_02: I have 101 contacts, but
they're all little blue-collar.
SPEAKER_00: I feel that you could go to
this guy, and if you had the upper hand,
SPEAKER_00: you're like, hey, we have this
conversation where we have a sniper
SPEAKER_00: pointing at you. How about we
have an open conversation now? You can
SPEAKER_00: definitely do that.
SPEAKER_02: I don't really feel like that
is going to help me.
SPEAKER_00: No, you're like, I... I don't
want you to rat us out, but we need to
SPEAKER_00: have an open talk.
SPEAKER_02: Right, and then the moment
he's out of sight, he does not help us,
SPEAKER_02: because now he's just
reporting us. I don't understand how that helps at
SPEAKER_02: all.
SPEAKER_00: I know. I saw it as a method
to gain information, but any plan that you
SPEAKER_00: have, I'm happy to hear.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I think if we pick a
right spot to isolate him, or to approach him
SPEAKER_02: when he's isolated, maybe
Faraday cage location, and then... We could
SPEAKER_02: present what we have, or one
of us could present what we have to him.
SPEAKER_02: And the fact that they are
cutting SoulSec out implies that there is a
SPEAKER_02: nefarious plot afoot. Okay,
maybe I misunderstood things. I'm like, we
SPEAKER_02: need somebody's help, not
somebody's information. Exactly. You know, I'm
SPEAKER_02: right here with you. But when
we have information that I think would
SPEAKER_02: help us so far, like, but it's
all...
SPEAKER_01: I don't know.
SPEAKER_02: But it's also lack of
concrete, right? Like from
SPEAKER_02: the information from the tube
that we pulled from the toilet and stuff
SPEAKER_02: is evidence that could assist
us without being, you know, nothing's a
SPEAKER_02: knockout blow for us yet.
SPEAKER_03: So, I mean, I guess when you
say you know a little SolSec, I mean, if
SPEAKER_03: you know some random SolSec
person, but like maybe they can't fix the
SPEAKER_03: problem, but like information
leads to knowing how to fix the problem,
SPEAKER_03: right? Like, that's how it is,
right? Knowing is half the battle. Like,
SPEAKER_03: SoulSec Joes, right?
SPEAKER_02: SoulSec Joes?
SPEAKER_03: It was like a G.I. Joe
reference. It wasn't good. Oh, I genuinely...
SPEAKER_03: That was terrible. Sorry about
that. I did pick up what you were putting
SPEAKER_03: down, Josh. I guess it would
have been better if I said Soleimani Joes.
SPEAKER_03: Maybe that would have been
better.
SPEAKER_02: Soleimani Joes, yeah. So what
if, though, we didn't approach as
SPEAKER_02: ourselves? What if we
approached as someone who had inside information
SPEAKER_02: from the Hall of Possibilities
and were leaky? I'm so confused. Are we
SPEAKER_02: asking someone for help or are
we asking them for just information? For
SPEAKER_02: help. I've said help
repeatedly. I'm talking about help.
SPEAKER_03: So I love help, but if it's
your people who you know who are connected,
SPEAKER_03: it's your choice. I don't know
about these spy shadowy people. My
SPEAKER_03: understanding is when you
shake their hands, you've got to count how
SPEAKER_03: many fingers you have after
you shake their hands. So you're the person
SPEAKER_03: who would know. Does your
character make a face when I say that?
SPEAKER_02: I'm just like, well, yes,
because why would you have to count your
SPEAKER_02: fingers? I'm not taking your
finger.
SPEAKER_03: You never heard that
reference? Like, after you shake someone's hand,
SPEAKER_03: you count your fingers?
SPEAKER_02: Man, apparently you're just
full of things I've never heard of tonight.
SPEAKER_02: No, I've never heard of that.
SPEAKER_03: It's like when someone's super
shifty, like, obviously you're not losing
SPEAKER_03: a finger, you don't realize,
but it's like the person is, like, that,
SPEAKER_03: like, greasy that, like, you
can't trust anything when you walk away
SPEAKER_03: from them. It's, like, even
more than, like, check to make sure your
SPEAKER_03: wallet's there.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, so I've heard count your
rings. I've never heard count your
SPEAKER_02: fingers. I
SPEAKER_02: haven't heard it, but I like
it. I'm using it.
SPEAKER_03: So does your character make
like an angst, like a face, like I'm being
SPEAKER_03: jerky about it? Because I
still don't know that you're a soul set
SPEAKER_03: person. I'm like, you know,
these are people that we know exist in
SPEAKER_03: society who are always
watching us. But I have no reason to assume that
SPEAKER_03: any of us are those people, is
my thing.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I would have made a
face, I guess, because I've just never heard
SPEAKER_02: of that phrase, and since you
brought it up, I guess I make a face,
SPEAKER_02: like, in that I'm just like, I
don't, it would be kind of an incredulous
SPEAKER_02: face, because I'm just like,
why are you?
SPEAKER_03: Okay, I'm sorry. I see that
I've overstepped. No, you're fine. I get
SPEAKER_03: that your soul sex spook is
like, is like a, I'm sure they're a good
SPEAKER_03: person. I'm sure, you know,
the rest of them, you know, you gotta watch
SPEAKER_03: your back. But I'm sure this
person is good, and my thing is, is, Even
SPEAKER_03: though you're not part of that
world, you're the next best thing. So if
SPEAKER_03: you think that we should ask
them for help, then we should. But if you
SPEAKER_03: think we should just ask for
information, then maybe that information
SPEAKER_03: will lead us to the person who
needs the help. The important thing is,
SPEAKER_03: is I don't really want to be a
criminal because, you know, it's hard to
SPEAKER_03: trust criminals. And the last
thing I want to say is, you know,
SPEAKER_03: Cass, you said about how
there's something suspicious going on. So the
SPEAKER_03: question is, is it the SoulSec
who are suspicious or the other side who
SPEAKER_03: are suspicious?
SPEAKER_02: It's definitely the Hall of
Possibilities. They wouldn't let SoulSec
SPEAKER_02: investigate it all. I mean,
they set us up. They were the ones there
SPEAKER_02: performing the setup. They
were the ones that shut us down, shut down
SPEAKER_02: the outside information, and
now they're keeping SoulSec out. This is
SPEAKER_02: entirely an operation for...
SPEAKER_03: Quite possibly. I mean, but
let's just flip it because I've been
SPEAKER_03: watching these spy thrillers,
right? Let's say that you were good and it
SPEAKER_03: was your building and then
someone hacked your building and they tried
SPEAKER_03: to make you look bad. Of
course you're not going to want people up in
SPEAKER_03: your business because you know
that you didn't do anything wrong and
SPEAKER_03: it's the other people who are
doing the bad thing.
SPEAKER_02: Except we retrieved the bug
and the data when we went back and checked
SPEAKER_02: out that building that
confirms that this is an inside job.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. See, I don't understand
that.
SPEAKER_03: My mind is more esoteric, and
by
SPEAKER_03: more esoteric, I mean
literally fixing things. But if you want us to
SPEAKER_03: make a power core to charge
you, Saichi, I think we could do that. I
SPEAKER_03: mean, I think I could do that.
But as opposed to everything else, yeah,
SPEAKER_03: I mean, I'm a smart guy, but
this sort of thinking is new to me.
SPEAKER_02: So Victor will step up and,
like, have this cup of coffee because I'm
SPEAKER_02: assuming this is, like, first
thing in the morning. Everybody's rolled
SPEAKER_02: out of their bedrolls. We're
trying to plan out our day. And he goes,
SPEAKER_02: wait a sec. How does finding
the bug prove that it was an inside job? I
SPEAKER_02: think I have missed a step
there. We got the data from the bug and the
SPEAKER_02: message that was sent with the
bug that, you know, they were leaking
SPEAKER_02: from the inside, leaking the
information to the...
SPEAKER_02: The party member or the
organization that was trying to
SPEAKER_02: take over and push out the
SPEAKER_02: syndicate as well as handle
the assassination because the
SPEAKER_02: official was more on the side
of open information
SPEAKER_02: and continuing to fall in line
with Soleimani
SPEAKER_01: So
SPEAKER_02: the bug was a plant from
someone inside the organization who's trying to
SPEAKER_02: commit the murder? No, there
was – okay. I
SPEAKER_02: apologize. I, Michael, am a
little confused on this. I'm trying to get
SPEAKER_02: the information in character
to kill myself.
SPEAKER_03: I'm a little – But I don't
want to push it, so I just accepted it
SPEAKER_03: because I didn't get it. And I
was like, I'm sure you're right. So I
SPEAKER_03: just backed down off of it.
SPEAKER_02: I'm trying to explain it in
character clearly as well.
SPEAKER_02: So do you remember what
happened yesterday when we came back and we told
SPEAKER_02: you about it?
SPEAKER_03: Wait, wait. Can we explain it
out of character first? I'd be fine with
SPEAKER_03: that. So then it'll be easy
for me to understand it in character if
SPEAKER_03: that's not obnoxious.
Otherwise, we'll just do it in character.
SPEAKER_02: No, let's do it in character.
Okay. You came
SPEAKER_02: yesterday with a bug that was
a small recording-type device with
SPEAKER_02: data on it that you got at the
Hall of Possibilities after you
SPEAKER_02: infiltrated there the day
after everything went down. So you
SPEAKER_02: came back from the Hall of
Possibilities with a bug. With the data, yes.
SPEAKER_02: With the whole robot thing,
yes. The little bomb that I defused, like
SPEAKER_02: all of that, yes.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. So yes, I remember that.
SPEAKER_01: So what? Go on. Maybe we go
over the information on the bug
SPEAKER_02: again then.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, so wait. Yeah, let's do
that first. Go ahead. Sure.
SPEAKER_01: And I'm sorry, it's been two
weeks. I don't remember this data point.
SPEAKER_01: I'm pulling up the bug data.
SPEAKER_02: I'm trying to pull. My
laptop's up to 7%. I'm trying to open up the
SPEAKER_02: foundry. Yeah, I have the
SPEAKER_02: notes on Dr. Mercer on the
information from the flash
SPEAKER_02: drive, but I didn't write down
the stuff from the bug, apparently.
SPEAKER_02: That's what he means. Yes. And
there was also the email that we entered.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I have the email. Yeah,
I think they were talking about the
SPEAKER_02: intercept, the email
intercept, but the bug was a bomb.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, the text message says,
this is the last time I can communicate.
SPEAKER_02: They killed the sender for
attempting to announce the information
SPEAKER_01: we gave him. Lose my number.
SPEAKER_01: And the bomb was going to...
SPEAKER_02: Come on, open up for me. Okay,
so the email is, okay, they found us out
SPEAKER_02: and killed the senator. Yes.
The email is separate from the bug, though.
SPEAKER_02: The bug is the bomb. The bug
is the bomb. The bomb was going to...
SPEAKER_02: Because we have that
information.
SPEAKER_03: Wait, so the email where they
said they found us out. Who are the two
SPEAKER_03: parties that are included
there with the they? Do we know who either the
SPEAKER_03: two parties are or neither?
SPEAKER_02: We know the one is a guy there
in the Hall of Possibilities, I forget
SPEAKER_02: his name, who was having to do
the work. He
SPEAKER_02: was the inside man.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, so someone in the Hall
of Possibilities... He knows that someone
SPEAKER_03: tried to kill them because
they were going to release the research, but
SPEAKER_03: he doesn't know who that
someone is, correct?
SPEAKER_02: So he knows that someone was
killed
SPEAKER_02: and that he doesn't want to be
a part of this anymore.
SPEAKER_03: Yes, but he doesn't know who
killed the senator, right?
SPEAKER_03: Well, at least he doesn't
allege who killed the senator, right?
SPEAKER_02: He doesn't allege who kills
the senator, yes. He probably knows, or at
SPEAKER_02: least knows who's responsible.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. We could hunt him now.
SPEAKER_01: Assuming he's not dead
already, but yeah.
SPEAKER_00: I think that— That guy, just
to remind people, that's his name, is the
SPEAKER_00: guy who had the data tube.
SPEAKER_02: I was saying, I kept looking
for Vincent. I thought it was Vincent. I'm
SPEAKER_02: going to copy this down
because apparently I didn't do that before.
SPEAKER_02: That's the guy who sent the
text message, correct?
SPEAKER_00: The guy who had the mobile
data tube from his ARM computer and
SPEAKER_00: flushed in the toilet that the
players then, you guys pulled it out of
SPEAKER_00: the toilet.
SPEAKER_02: Right, and it was a bump. I
just want to make sure that's the guy who
SPEAKER_02: was in the bathroom, right?
That's not who he was texting. That's the
SPEAKER_02: guy, yeah.
SPEAKER_01: That's the guy. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. I don't know why I
didn't write his name down.
SPEAKER_00: And also, to be clear, you
guys don't know exactly who he was sending it
SPEAKER_00: to.
SPEAKER_02: No, it just says that they
killed him and lose my number. It doesn't say
SPEAKER_02: who's losing his number.
SPEAKER_01: Right.
SPEAKER_03: Um, so, okay, so we have a
doctor who we do know, who knows that someone
SPEAKER_03: was killed before he releases
the data. He's kind of, I don't want to be
SPEAKER_03: part of this, whether, and is
trying to get away from it. He may or may
SPEAKER_03: not know who the people are.
And then there's, I guess we'll wait for
SPEAKER_03: Kolb to find his stuff. Um, In
the meantime, perhaps since we
SPEAKER_03: live in a delightful police
state that keeps all of us safe, generally,
SPEAKER_03: maybe we want to start with,
you know, seeing if that
SPEAKER_03: mammalian can extend our IDs
so that we
SPEAKER_03: don't get flagged everywhere
we go?
SPEAKER_02: Our facial protection. Right,
but he wanted us, he was going to do that
SPEAKER_02: on terms of us working for
him.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, I hear. We don't have to
do that. I agree. I don't want to be a
SPEAKER_03: criminal. What are we going to
do in 12 hours when we need to go outside
SPEAKER_03: otherwise, is my question.
SPEAKER_01: Be criminals. I hate working
with criminals. What should we do?
SPEAKER_03: We are criminals, so we have
to work with criminals. No, no,
SPEAKER_03: no. We're up against a wall.
Criminals are people who want to do crimes.
SPEAKER_03: We're people who are forced to
do crimes.
SPEAKER_02: Really, it's alleged. We're
allegedly criminals. We're vigilantes is
SPEAKER_02: what we are.
SPEAKER_03: You have a poor concept of
what criminals are.
SPEAKER_02: If we were stopping other
people from committing crimes, then we would
SPEAKER_02: be vigilantes.
SPEAKER_03: We're stopping the government
from committing these crimes eventually in
SPEAKER_03: the future, probably. Also,
almost all criminals are people who have
SPEAKER_03: their backs against the law.
That is what crime is. It's a necessity.
SPEAKER_03: They're people who want to
destroy society and rip it down from the
SPEAKER_03: insides, who have no respect
for law and order. Ah, that's, uh, you were
SPEAKER_03: wrong. You were wrong. Yes.
SPEAKER_02: No, no, he's not. I've
definitely met people who want to just watch the
SPEAKER_02: world burn.
SPEAKER_03: Yes, but this is a small
number. Most criminals need to be criminals to
SPEAKER_03: get back.
SPEAKER_02: Not really.
SPEAKER_01: Not in my experience.
SPEAKER_03: Okay. I just want to say out
of character, you do not associate my
SPEAKER_03: personal beliefs with my
characters' beliefs. It may be vaguely
SPEAKER_03: divergent. Game respects. I'm
judging all of you as players.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, game respects.
SPEAKER_00: I'm taking notes. I'm going to
come back at all of you later.
SPEAKER_01: Mm-hmm.
SPEAKER_03: This is all sarcasm. We
understand. So, Emma,
SPEAKER_03: I hear what you're saying, and
I don't want to be a criminal either.
SPEAKER_01: So, I guess my question is, if
we don't go to him, what are we doing
SPEAKER_01: instead? I... I don't have any
better ideas,
SPEAKER_01: so I... Yeah, I agree.
SPEAKER_02: Like, I... I'm of the mind
that we have a potential
SPEAKER_02: ally in SoulSec and we have
leads that we can
SPEAKER_02: feed them. I think that would
help mobilize them
SPEAKER_02: towards clearing our name, but
it's about how do we approach and pass
SPEAKER_02: upon this information. Okay,
who is this potential ally? Are you talking
SPEAKER_02: about this Luke Moreau who was
in the bathroom? Because he seemed to
SPEAKER_02: want nothing to do with
anything anymore. No, I'm talking about the
SPEAKER_02: SoulSec that I heard being
denied entry there.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, I thought you meant your
SoulSec person. I'm sorry. I misunderstood
SPEAKER_03: that too.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, so when I was there, I
snuck up on them. I wasn't that close
SPEAKER_02: enough to overhear the
conversation. SolSec was trying to get in and
SPEAKER_02: investigate, and they were
being denied access. Yeah, I kind of
SPEAKER_02: remember this.
SPEAKER_00: That's Inspector Mark Valois.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, so I think Inspector
Mark already has an
SPEAKER_02: intention to investigate, and
if we can— Perhaps feed
SPEAKER_02: him this information through a
third party or help him to stumble across
SPEAKER_02: it that we could motivate him
towards uncovering the truth without
SPEAKER_02: necessarily exposing
ourselves. I see where you're headed. You want to
SPEAKER_02: feed him some breadcrumbs to
push him towards where we want him to be to
SPEAKER_02: – as a – Byproduct of where
his investigation goes being
SPEAKER_02: the clearing of our names.
Precisely.
SPEAKER_03: Eventually, we will have to
meet this man in person, no? No.
SPEAKER_03: So, later on, Cass is going to
tell us the information when he
SPEAKER_03: unravels it. But in the
meantime, we want to find this guy and see if he
SPEAKER_03: can be an ally. And if not, we
can kind of squeeze him By basically
SPEAKER_03: being like, listen, you're
gonna get killed like us if you don't help us
SPEAKER_03: anyway, right?
SPEAKER_01: Right?
SPEAKER_03: Not by us, but by other
people. See, that was an
SPEAKER_03: absolutely cold killer idea.
How do you say that you are not criminal?
SPEAKER_03: Are you trying to, you know
what, I'm starting to think maybe 2-3% of
SPEAKER_03: criminals actually don't want
to be criminals. We're those 2-3% is what
SPEAKER_03: I'm saying. That's what I'm
saying. Yeah, I think you might be a
SPEAKER_03: criminal. That was very
brutal. Listen, right, like, if he
SPEAKER_03: doesn't want to help fix our
society, what is he doing anyway? Yeah, no,
SPEAKER_03: don't worry. I'm proud. I'm
seeing you blossom into this new life. It's
SPEAKER_03: inspiring. So here's my
proposal. Let's go and we'll ask him to help us.
SPEAKER_03: And then if he doesn't want
to, we mention how maybe he'll die terribly,
SPEAKER_03: you know, like we probably
would. And then, you know, push him a little
SPEAKER_03: further. And then we go and
get, you know, new identification so that,
SPEAKER_03: you know, If someone tries to
leak back to the fake IDs that we're using
SPEAKER_03: now, we already have new ones.
See, I think that
SPEAKER_02: that is an approach. I'm not
sure that is the approach that I would
SPEAKER_02: throw my weight behind. I
would prefer to air gap.
SPEAKER_02: Right. And we just so happen
to know an information broker that we have
SPEAKER_02: met. Who owes us a favor.
SPEAKER_02: Well, we've got goodwill with
him now.
SPEAKER_03: Goodwill. Whatever we wish to
call it. We have it
SPEAKER_01: with him. Kind of. His name is
Lucent. He's a red prick.
SPEAKER_02: Now, the other side of that
is... We have these veils that last for
SPEAKER_02: another day. If we did want to
push a contact with us...
SPEAKER_02: Right now, while we have these
veils, but then we need to make sure that
SPEAKER_02: he thinks that we are not us
if we approach him in veils not as who we
SPEAKER_02: are. Do the veils—this is a
question for Patrick—the veils I know
SPEAKER_02: protect us from electronic
observation. Do they change our face
SPEAKER_02: appearance from when we're
standing next to each other? Yes. Okay. They
SPEAKER_02: are like full chameleon
droughts.
SPEAKER_00: They are— Genericizing your
faces.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. Very cool.
SPEAKER_00: Because there are cameras that
are not necessarily computers that are
SPEAKER_00: still going to be recording.
They have to make sure that those just
SPEAKER_00: record generic people. Yeah.
SPEAKER_02: Does anyone here think they
might be able to fix it? What did you say?
SPEAKER_02: I'm sorry. Yeah, I don't know
why I keep that, like, intermediate. It
SPEAKER_02: keeps ducking in and out. Does
anyone think that they would be able to
SPEAKER_02: repair them?
SPEAKER_01: Is it a computer thing?
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, Keith, you're a fucking
whiz kid,
SPEAKER_03: right, with a wrench? Yes,
you've said you are good at fixing things.
SPEAKER_03: Is this a computer thing or is
this a mechanical thing? Mechanical
SPEAKER_03: things I'm all about.
Computers I know how to turn on.
SPEAKER_00: So I just want you guys to
know this is like things that are made in a
SPEAKER_00: factory. So you guys might be
able to get another day or two out of them
SPEAKER_00: with really fancy rolls. But
if the rolls aren't so fancy, you would
SPEAKER_00: break them now.
SPEAKER_01: I see. Oh, rolling them dice!
SPEAKER_03: So I can try and... You're
saying with a mechanics roll, I can maybe
SPEAKER_03: extend it, is what you're
saying.
SPEAKER_00: Well, I'm saying it is... You
would basically need three layers of
SPEAKER_00: success on mechanics and
another person to do three layers of success on
SPEAKER_00: computers to get a day out of
one. Aren't we like computer dummies,
SPEAKER_00: though? What? Aren't we like
computer dummies, though? I think we are.
SPEAKER_00: And then every day that you
try to extend it, you need to get to a
SPEAKER_00: higher level of success on
both. So today, to
SPEAKER_00: get the fourth day, you need
three and three. Tomorrow, to get the fifth
SPEAKER_00: day, you need four and four.
SPEAKER_01: I'm
SPEAKER_03: hearing that we have them for
this last day. I'm hearing that we're
SPEAKER_03: having them for maybe one more
day.
SPEAKER_01: Could I fix it?
SPEAKER_00: I could. You could also just
try to jury-rig them when they're broken.
SPEAKER_00: Yes. Like, then you at least
have pulled them as long as you can. And
SPEAKER_00: then just try to be like, hey,
I got nothing better to do while I'm
SPEAKER_00: sitting in the warehouse.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, put something around
with some broken gear to harvest it or use
SPEAKER_03: it.
SPEAKER_00: While they're currently
working, don't follow my excuse and update the
SPEAKER_00: BIOS while you still need to
use it.
SPEAKER_01: I've done that. I have done
that.
SPEAKER_00: When you have a spare, yeah,
feel free to mess with them.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, so what I'm hearing is
that it's too difficult to fix them and
SPEAKER_02: that it's very distasteful for
a lot of us to go work for a mobster. But
SPEAKER_02: we're not coming up with any
alternative plans.
SPEAKER_00: Let me bring up one of the
plans that hasn't really been brought up. You
SPEAKER_00: guys could go to the
corporation at TransStar. Oh, right. In
SPEAKER_00: TransStar, you are
automatically going to be... As long as you stay in
SPEAKER_00: the trans or sexual exchange,
you are completely free from the law.
SPEAKER_01: Interesting.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, we might want to go do
that, if only so it gives us more time to
SPEAKER_02: work on things.
SPEAKER_03: Can we turn off our veils
while we're there so we preserve the hours we
SPEAKER_03: have, or no?
SPEAKER_00: Well, the moment a veil is
activated, the timer starts. You can take it
SPEAKER_00: off your face so people see
you for real, but... It's like a glow
SPEAKER_00: stick. That's a better way of
saying it.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_02: Do they even make glow sticks
still? Man, those were so...
SPEAKER_03: They do for emergency stuff. I
have children. Yes, they do.
SPEAKER_01: They still make them. Agreed,
agreed.
SPEAKER_02: I had one on my wrist on July
SPEAKER_00: 4th. I'm uninformed. I only
have a child. Everyone's like, I have
SPEAKER_00: children. I know these
children. I go to Burning Man events. They are
SPEAKER_00: everywhere.
SPEAKER_03: When you get to be a little
older, Patrick, you will see them again.
SPEAKER_03: Don't worry.
SPEAKER_02: That makes me so happy. I
loved those as a kid. I thought they were just
SPEAKER_02: freaking magic. Sorry, I
didn't mean to derail, but that was totally
SPEAKER_02: just a hot nostalgia moment
for me. No, don't worry.
SPEAKER_03: You didn't derail. I'm still
reeling. They're not magic?
SPEAKER_02: Magic's not real. By the way,
is my microphone better if I turn off my
SPEAKER_02: camera?
SPEAKER_03: You sound great. Yeah, it's
similar, but we still hear
SPEAKER_03: you.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, most of the time
SPEAKER_03: we hear you.
SPEAKER_02: It was more that it kept
cutting in and out for me, and I just was like,
SPEAKER_02: I think I was just stressing
things a little too hard.
SPEAKER_01: Sure.
SPEAKER_02: We'll make it work. I didn't
want to be in the room with the AC man,
SPEAKER_02: that's all I want in life.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, so I'm sorry that I
tried to get us to be criminals. I see that
SPEAKER_03: that did not go over well. I
just worry that we can't
SPEAKER_03: in 12 hours, you know, travel
freely. But I hear, let's not do that. So
SPEAKER_03: what do you all want to do
first? I suggested three things. One, we go
SPEAKER_03: to the guy who sent the email
and kind of pressure on him. Two, we try
SPEAKER_03: and go to the Zolzak person.
Three, we try and get the new veils. And
SPEAKER_03: so if no one wants to do those
three, that's fine. Let's do something
SPEAKER_03: else. I'm open to it. I'm
doing whatever you guys think that is
SPEAKER_03: mostly moral, and let's do it.
I think if we're looking to do
SPEAKER_03: morally good things, try and
head back into
SPEAKER_03: our previous lives and our
previous standing, I think Inspector
SPEAKER_03: Valois is an interesting move.
I do not know how to do this air-gapping.
SPEAKER_03: That we are speaking of. So I
put it in the good faith that I have of
SPEAKER_03: those intelligence people who
we do have here, it seems, in some number.
SPEAKER_03: We do? I'm just guessing. I'm
just drawing contact clues from what
SPEAKER_03: they're saying. Oh! I
misunderstood! Great big scope.
SPEAKER_03: They immediately went off to
go collect information. They called it
SPEAKER_03: intelligence. They got the
crazy hypertech information. Like, they're
SPEAKER_03: very good at their jobs. I'm
sure they would also be good at doing this
SPEAKER_03: Inspector Valois business. I
will help what I can. I did make those
SPEAKER_03: communication relays that we
should all still have on our persons. He
SPEAKER_03: points around to the group.
Everyone remembers their radio?
SPEAKER_01: Victor Nod. Okay. That's good.
SPEAKER_01: I have no idea how we would
SPEAKER_03: do the inspector stuff.
Someone else would have to do that. I can keep
SPEAKER_03: security on that to make sure
that we stay safe, but it does sound like
SPEAKER_03: a sound idea to try and,
SPEAKER_01: you know, the fucking feds are
trying to investigate the weird
SPEAKER_01: corruption
SPEAKER_03: in the feds.
SPEAKER_02: I don't understand air gap
either.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, it seems difficult to
try and make this man our ally without ever
SPEAKER_03: meeting him to tell him what
has happened. But I don't know, I don't,
SPEAKER_03: you know, that there could be
a way to do that that I am unaware of. If
SPEAKER_03: I may, what I
SPEAKER_02: think Cass is putting out
here, and Cass, correct me if I'm wrong, is
SPEAKER_02: if we go and approach the
SoulSec guy directly as ourselves... If it is
SPEAKER_02: later found out that he knew
that we, when we were wanted criminals, met
SPEAKER_02: with us and then didn't turn
us in, that puts him and everything
SPEAKER_02: he's done right in the wood
chipper.
SPEAKER_03: That's a risk we should be
willing to take, but I understand if we don't
SPEAKER_03: want to do that. I understand.
SPEAKER_02: Well, if he's able to get us
our lives back, and then two days later
SPEAKER_02: they go, oh... He met with
them when they were criminals. He's a
SPEAKER_02: criminal. Everything he's done
is criminal. We lose our lives again.
SPEAKER_02: Whereas if we insulate him
from us, if we have an intermediary interact
SPEAKER_02: with him, then we can give him
the breadcrumbs to get him
SPEAKER_02: to take the steps necessary
for us to clear our names
SPEAKER_02: without him having directly
interacted with us. Thus, he is not a
SPEAKER_02: criminal for having interacted
with us.
SPEAKER_03: So the step we need to take
then right now, if we want to do that, which
SPEAKER_03: we could do, is go to Lucen.
That's the info broker that you mentioned
SPEAKER_03: before when you brought up
this idea before. Yes, Lucen. That is the way
SPEAKER_03: I would approach it. And
that's what people would count as their
SPEAKER_03: alternative to working with
this Delphine fellow.
SPEAKER_02: Well, I was actually going to
propose that
SPEAKER_02: When we give him that
information and let him do some of that work, that
SPEAKER_02: we do go to the Dolphine and
see what kind of jobs need to
SPEAKER_01: happen to
SPEAKER_02: keep us in veils until this is
resolved.
SPEAKER_03: I like the idea because it's
dangerous, but I know other people might
SPEAKER_03: not. That is... Dangerously
close to double-dipping. Who knows
SPEAKER_03: how the people that we would
be treating for help would feel about that,
SPEAKER_03: but I find that interesting
and fun.
SPEAKER_02: I just would rather not commit
crimes that when our names are cleared,
SPEAKER_02: we are then held accountable
for the crimes we committed.
SPEAKER_01: That is true.
SPEAKER_02: That just seems a little
self-sabotaging.
SPEAKER_03: If we go to an inspector and
say, oh, we're innocent, and then go blow
SPEAKER_03: up some apartment building,
that's going to be difficult.
SPEAKER_02: Well, that's why I think
talking to them, figuring out what type of jobs
SPEAKER_02: is the key. Because we've
already delivered a dog to a guy, and that
SPEAKER_02: seems super sketchy, like
there was something else going on. If there
SPEAKER_02: are... Low-grade
transportation, oh, we don't really know what's going
SPEAKER_02: on jobs that keep us alive
while other people
SPEAKER_02: try to clear our names. I
think there's some validity there. And if
SPEAKER_02: half of us don't want that,
then the other half of us get a little dirty
SPEAKER_02: to keep us
SPEAKER_01: all safe. Barely a crime.
SPEAKER_01: I do want to
SPEAKER_02: state that I do hear what you
are saying, Emma, that you are concerned
SPEAKER_02: about life after this as well.
I guess I'm a
SPEAKER_02: little in the, I want to get
through this. And I'm looking at
SPEAKER_02: the tree right in front of me.
And you're looking at the whole forest,
SPEAKER_02: which I appreciate. No, and I
was going to say something similar in
SPEAKER_02: that, like, I don't think
we're necessarily talking at cross purposes,
SPEAKER_02: but we're coming at it from
multiple angles, and we need to focus our
SPEAKER_02: attention on fewer angles.
SPEAKER_03: Alright, I can focus our
attention on fewer angles. We can do the
SPEAKER_03: Inspector Valois thing, and
then, after hitting his information, a good
SPEAKER_03: place for us to stay safe from
a number of our threats would be
SPEAKER_03: Trendstart.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I like that idea best,
at least for now.
SPEAKER_03: Go to Lucen... Have Lucen
reach out to this Inspector
SPEAKER_03: Valois, make our way towards
Transtar, be ready for people still to
SPEAKER_03: maybe come for us if we stay
too long, you know? It's Transtar, that
SPEAKER_03: means there is no law there,
which means Delphine will have easy access
SPEAKER_03: to Transtar as well. So if we
piss off Delphine in whatever we do
SPEAKER_03: with talking to Inspector
Valois, there is still very ample
SPEAKER_03: opportunities for Delphine to
come knock at our door and be like, So,
SPEAKER_03: what's up? What are we doing?
Stuff like that. But, if he does,
SPEAKER_03: we'll kill him.
SPEAKER_01: So,
SPEAKER_02: that's fine. Whoa! You always
jump to the, like, most violent
SPEAKER_02: conclusion?
SPEAKER_03: I think, what, if I'm counting
correctly, it's five years of expert,
SPEAKER_03: competent, and loyal service
to, you know, Solar Marines.
SPEAKER_02: I get it. When you're built
like a hammer, everything looks like a nail.
SPEAKER_02: But keep that in the far back
of your mind, you know? That's a
SPEAKER_02: last resort option. We have
many other avenues to explore first.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, let's call that Plan K,
Plan Kill Ever 1. We still have
SPEAKER_02: A through J to go through
before we get there.
SPEAKER_03: I love this. Great double
joke. Yes, yes, yes. So, you may have noticed,
SPEAKER_03: Emma, that I've been looking
at you a little hard for the
SPEAKER_01: last minute.
SPEAKER_02: Okay. I am pretty cute.
SPEAKER_01: She is pretty cute.
SPEAKER_02: I just make eye contact in a
kind of, like, what are you looking at kind
SPEAKER_02: of way, but I don't think I
would say anything about it.
SPEAKER_01: Not yet, anyway.
SPEAKER_01: Okie dokie. I mean, unless
you...
SPEAKER_02: Is there some... Are you doing
something that looks suspicious? Like, I
SPEAKER_02: don't understand. I'm just
like, what?
SPEAKER_03: No, it was after he said,
like, basically that you're a spy. So since
SPEAKER_03: then, I've been, like, looking
at you very...
SPEAKER_01: No one said she's a spy. No
one said she was a spy.
SPEAKER_03: No, no, no. Yeah, it was
Peter. Yeah, he was definitely like,
SPEAKER_03: you're the spy person because
you know all the stuff. He was super,
SPEAKER_03: super obtuse about it.
SPEAKER_02: I thought he just said that
you were the intelligence person.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_02: That's not a spy. That can be
a government worker.
SPEAKER_03: I understood what I
understood. If your character comes to the
SPEAKER_03: conclusion that that means
spy, I'm sure your character could do that.
SPEAKER_03: That is not what he said. He
said intelligence. If you want to be
SPEAKER_03: technical, her job is
counterintelligence, which is the opposite of
SPEAKER_03: being a spy. That's true, I
don't know the difference in any of these
SPEAKER_03: things. Exactly, right? You do
not have a good grasp of what
SPEAKER_03: intelligence would mean, so if
someone says it, I can very much see you
SPEAKER_03: going, he means spy.
SPEAKER_01: There's a spy. I see what
you're saying.
SPEAKER_01: I don't know, I appreciate
SPEAKER_02: that apparently everyone knows
my background, I just wanted to, I'm
SPEAKER_02: supposed to be a spy, I was
trying to keep it secret, but like,
SPEAKER_01: You are.
SPEAKER_02: No, I don't know. I don't know
anything. It just keeps thrown around.
SPEAKER_02: So, like, I don't know. Maybe
I just dropped the whole pretense of
SPEAKER_02: illusion.
SPEAKER_01: You don't have to do anything.
SPEAKER_03: You can explain that he didn't
say, like, later on when we talk, you can
SPEAKER_03: be like, he didn't say spy. He
said intelligence. Because I know some
SPEAKER_03: intelligence people. And then
I'd be like, sure.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: I think the other thing to
remember is probably two-thirds of the people
SPEAKER_00: have worked for SolSec in some
point of their entire career.
SPEAKER_00: Everyone has sold out
something. Few people have sold it to the point of
SPEAKER_00: being the actual
administrator.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, Cass is leading the way
on feeding information to SoulSack.
SPEAKER_02: And Victor's on board with
that, and
SPEAKER_02: backing up Cass with the
funneling it through a third party. Yeah, I
SPEAKER_02: feel like that's at least a
good first step. It gets us moving it out of
SPEAKER_02: this circle that we're kind of
SPEAKER_03: stuck in. Okay. Yeah, I don't
want to push things that people don't want
SPEAKER_03: to do.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah. I met Lucen over in...
SPEAKER_03: There is a very well-made
write-up on this entire district that he
SPEAKER_03: resides in. It is the one with
the... The Great Big Travel Hub, which
SPEAKER_03: might be the location of
TransStar as well. Like, they might be right
SPEAKER_03: next to each other. I have to
find the district, though.
SPEAKER_01: It's in the southwest, I
believe. You mean the Customs and Immigration?
SPEAKER_01: Yes. Yeah,
SPEAKER_01: he's clicking. It's to the
left of the TransStar sector.
SPEAKER_03: Yes. Because that is where he
was doing a bunch of his
SPEAKER_03: brokering, and we chatted him
up on his wares, criminal
SPEAKER_03: seller, and then he was like,
oh, I have a job.
SPEAKER_00: When we have time, I would
like to hit up my
SPEAKER_00: contact in the other world and
ask him about the dolphin and the
SPEAKER_00: random man that we decided to
work for that we found in an alley.
SPEAKER_00: I mean, it's a dolphin that
helped us, and this random man that we found
SPEAKER_00: in the alley that everyone
wants to work for instead. So, the random man
SPEAKER_00: who works for an alley, your
contact says, is like three tiers below the
SPEAKER_00: dolphin, but he works for the
same organization. Okay. So.
SPEAKER_01: You're not crossing the
strings by working with him. No.
SPEAKER_01: Which is interesting
SPEAKER_03: for us to know. It means that
we know for a fact that Delphine is going
SPEAKER_03: to know that we are doing
this.
SPEAKER_01: Let's cut out the middleman.
Well,
SPEAKER_01: I think one
SPEAKER_00: of the other kind of important
things to think about is when you go to
SPEAKER_00: the president of a
corporation, you have to kind of make better returns
SPEAKER_00: versus if you go to a middle
manager. If I learned one
SPEAKER_00: thing from
SPEAKER_03: playing MMOs, you always go to
the head of the organization to get all
SPEAKER_03: your quests. Is it?
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_02: Well, then you become the head
of the organization.
SPEAKER_01: Is there a difference? I mean,
they're all criminals, right?
SPEAKER_03: I mean, I'm assuming we're
still following through on our... Yes. Yes.
SPEAKER_03: Perfect.
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan makes the goddamn
link, and he will bring, I
SPEAKER_03: believe, Kolb's character over
to kind of voice this
SPEAKER_03: plan a little bit more,
facilitate this conversation.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, so it sounds like
there's, like, two at least break-off groups.
SPEAKER_00: One is going to try to get you
guys access into TransStar. One is going
SPEAKER_00: to try to... Communicate with
the Underworld people to send data to
SPEAKER_00: SolSec. Is that kind of the
slip that we're seeing?
SPEAKER_01: Yes. Sounds reasonable. Who
wants to be in what group?
SPEAKER_02: I will be a data broker.
SPEAKER_01: Keenan will be a data broker.
SPEAKER_00: I'll be in whichever group
feels they could use a little extra security
SPEAKER_00: support.
SPEAKER_01: I'll be in whichever group the
group wants me to be in, because I get
SPEAKER_01: along. I'd like to try the
SPEAKER_01: Transtar piece. Yeah, I'll do
that as well. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Victor, whoop. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: And...
SPEAKER_01: I want to get caught up.
SPEAKER_03: What are we doing in TransStar
and what are we doing in SoulSec?
SPEAKER_00: So, just real quick... Oh, go
ahead. You probably want to
SPEAKER_00: have the ape do the Underworld
stuff since he's going to be less
SPEAKER_00: genetically supported.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. If we're thinking about
that stuff.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so we have Josh and
SPEAKER_01: Annette and Kiernan as
SPEAKER_01: the other people to be kind of
organized.
SPEAKER_01: I'll do Underground as well.
Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So, as Josh wants to be more
up and up, you probably should go to
SPEAKER_01: Transtar. Sure.
SPEAKER_01: And Kiernan, where do you want
to go?
SPEAKER_03: He's going with the Data
Broker. He knows this person
SPEAKER_03: from our last interaction. So
he's more familiar in this space. And it
SPEAKER_03: could also go bad.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. So you go off and you
ride... You're the group who's taking the
SPEAKER_00: trike. Because you want to be
able to get in and out if you need to.
SPEAKER_01: And... Let me get to...
SPEAKER_01: Okay. So you go to the same
alley,
SPEAKER_00: and you see a man
SPEAKER_00: coming out from the alley, but
you do not see Luce in there.
SPEAKER_01: Right.
SPEAKER_00: Are you going to go deeper in
the alley, or are you going to send the
SPEAKER_00: droid? What are you going to
do?
SPEAKER_03: Honestly, not a very bad idea.
Though I do not
SPEAKER_03: think we need panic such yet.
I don't know if we need to go deeper
SPEAKER_03: into this alley, or we should
maybe just, you know, walk the block, see
SPEAKER_03: if he hasn't set up somewhere
else. There's no reason to think he hasn't
SPEAKER_03: just ended
SPEAKER_01: up in a different part of the
neighborhood. I would like to recon,
SPEAKER_01: please. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Kieran is just looking around
to see if anyone is watching us.
SPEAKER_00: You see another version of
your guys' exact trike down the street.
SPEAKER_01: Hmm. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So they make a model down the
street, and he's just saying this kind of
SPEAKER_03: absentmindedly to the rest
around.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, because it's stolen, and
they said he didn't think they were
SPEAKER_01: coming looking for it.
SPEAKER_01: So what does that mean? So you
guys are going to walk up to it? They
SPEAKER_01: could have took another one.
Maybe they did come looking for it.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_02: I'm going to ask Coach if I'm
just hanging out with me while they go
SPEAKER_02: check it out.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah. I'm gonna just shrug,
remind myself where my shotgun
SPEAKER_03: is.
SPEAKER_01: Well, who's coming with me?
SPEAKER_01: Would Streetwise roll help us
out here?
We're gonna roll, or what?
SPEAKER_01: Oh, gosh, I'm having to roll
streetwise. If you want me to roll
SPEAKER_01: streetwise, too, I
SPEAKER_00: got it. There is a cantina up
SPEAKER_00: ahead where it is parked
called La Porte Fiel, The Wallet.
SPEAKER_01: Well, let's hope they don't
have a
SPEAKER_01: check-in locker. He's going to
head for the building.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: So you guys walk on up, and
there is a big cybered-up
SPEAKER_00: bouncer outside of it. And he
says,
SPEAKER_00: you're here for business or
pleasure?
SPEAKER_03: And at this point, do we still
have our veils?
SPEAKER_00: Yep.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: This is when you go...
SPEAKER_03: We never got like a... I'm not
just forgetting a code word we may have
SPEAKER_03: gotten. For some reason, I've
got that in my mind. Did we ever get
SPEAKER_03: something like that? I'd have
to look in my... It's Fidelio. It's
SPEAKER_03: Fidelio. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: I mean, we know his name is
Lucen.
SPEAKER_01: I don't know if we drop it
right at the door.
SPEAKER_03: He looks at the other two and
is like, am I being the spokesman? Okay,
SPEAKER_03: it's me. Pleasure. Pleasure.
SPEAKER_02: Other two, I'm staying back.
I'm waiting for you guys to scout it out.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, we're doing pleasure.
SPEAKER_01: Pleasure then, huh? Got day's
pay burning in my pocket. Come on in.
SPEAKER_01: He opens the door. Walks right
in. Are we all going
SPEAKER_01: through?
SPEAKER_00: Doesn't sound like it. Unless
you're next to him, he's going to ask
SPEAKER_00: everyone else who comes by.
SPEAKER_02: No, I am not going to enter
the facility.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. You're like, I'm a
robot. I don't know business nor pleasure.
SPEAKER_01: Exactly. I will stand and
stare. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Is anyone going in with Peter?
I'll go in with
SPEAKER_01: Peter. This is the group that
I'm not with, right? That's right. You
SPEAKER_01: want to not be a criminal. I'm
trying to avoid it, but I'm more open to
SPEAKER_01: it than, let's say, Emma.
Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So, I guess also is, Damien,
are you going in? You had the
SPEAKER_01: Streetwise role. Yeah, I'll go
in with Twitter.
SPEAKER_01: Yes. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: So, as you guys go in, you see
people laying
SPEAKER_00: back in reclining chairs up
against the wall as
SPEAKER_00: very bass-heavy music is being
played with flashing lights. One of the
SPEAKER_00: things that does seem a little
odd, though, is there's not a lot of
SPEAKER_00: people moving around. Almost
everyone is either sitting in a chair or
SPEAKER_00: leaning up against a bar.
SPEAKER_01: I just glance at Zoe and
SPEAKER_03: walk around. The bouncer does
not follow us. We are not being led by
SPEAKER_03: anyone. We are in this space.
We are not being led. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: If you do nothing for a few
moments, you can see that a waitress would
SPEAKER_00: be coming your way.
SPEAKER_03: Sure. He's doing his best not
to be caught unawares or anything like
SPEAKER_03: that. He is just scanning the
room looking for Lucent.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. I'm happy to take a
recon roll. It is going to be with the Bane
SPEAKER_00: with the flashing lights and
the loud music.
SPEAKER_01: All right. Recon.
SPEAKER_01: Bane. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Wow. You had a perfect roll
even with the Bane. Yeah. Oh, my. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, something just takes
over a little bit. He's
SPEAKER_03: regarding this.
SPEAKER_00: You see him standing... Well,
you see him sitting in a chair next to
SPEAKER_00: two other people, and you see
he's rifling through one person's pockets.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, um...
SPEAKER_03: He will communicate that he's
a spotted Lucid and what he's doing to
SPEAKER_03: Zoi, and just be like, I say
we
SPEAKER_03: circle the establishment, wait
for him to finish whatever business that
SPEAKER_03: is, and then,
SPEAKER_01: you know. Well, he doesn't
SPEAKER_01: seem
SPEAKER_00: to be slow, or... He's taking
his time rifling through these
SPEAKER_00: people's pockets and poking at
their phones and putting their phone
SPEAKER_00: back.
SPEAKER_03: Okay. All right. Shit. Zoe,
anything? I
SPEAKER_03: mean, I'm just going to go up
and tell him that we have others who have
SPEAKER_01: to speak with him about more
business.
SPEAKER_01: All right. Yeah, we should
just go up and talk to him.
SPEAKER_03: Fuck yeah. I mean, there you
go. He speaks. And then he will start in
SPEAKER_03: that direction,
mission-focused, just kind of, you know, if anyone was
SPEAKER_03: sharp of eye. He's very loose
and oriented.
SPEAKER_01: He's a straight line to him.
He's, like,
SPEAKER_01: surprising to see you here.
From
SPEAKER_01: Upright Simpson to Going into
a drug den. Ah, well,
SPEAKER_01: you know. A forgetful face is
easy to go many places.
SPEAKER_01: Well, how can I help you?
SPEAKER_03: We have more business for you
that hopefully will be of some intrigue
SPEAKER_03: to you more than these
pauper's pockets.
SPEAKER_01: Is this something you would be
amenable to?
SPEAKER_00: Sure, but don't ever think
that a pauper's pockets is
SPEAKER_00: lacking of value. Many of
these people have important friends.
SPEAKER_01: Ah, you know. To the expert
goes the spoils, I presume.
SPEAKER_01: Come with me. Where are we
going?
SPEAKER_01: Outside. Hmm. I'd rather do
our business in here.
SPEAKER_01: Can you find us a private
space while I get my friends?
SPEAKER_00: Sure, but trust me, there's
not a lot of witnesses that are awake here
SPEAKER_00: as he slaps the guy next to
him. And the guy's still totally conscious.
SPEAKER_03: All right. And I will ask you
to refrain from that kind of stuff in the
SPEAKER_03: more queasy company of mine.
But... Yes,
SPEAKER_03: yes, I will go get them.
SPEAKER_01: We're safe in here, right?
It's a drug team.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, he looks at you like,
what? That's why I'm here.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, turns around. Okay, so
SPEAKER_01: you're going to go outside and
get people who didn't come in? Which I
SPEAKER_01: think is just a nap. I think
it's Annette and
SPEAKER_01: Colt. Either way, he gets them
both. Yeah, Colt was hanging out.
SPEAKER_03: Me and Sonchi. Hey, he gets
back to the pair and kind of just
SPEAKER_03: looks expectantly. Okay, we're
in.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. You come with me now.
Yep, we'll follow. All right.
SPEAKER_01: It's a drug bin. It's unsafe.
Be ready.
SPEAKER_01: I'm immune to most drugs, but
I'll
SPEAKER_02: keep my eye out.
SPEAKER_03: I was mostly talking to
Caspian. I have remembered your
SPEAKER_03: good work that you've done in
our previous service.
SPEAKER_01: I trust you, do not worry.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, yeah, I am not immune to
most drugs, but I will keep my eye out.
SPEAKER_03: I'm also more afraid of you
getting stabbed rather than drugged, though
SPEAKER_03: you might get drugged or
stabbed or shot. Gee, thanks. This is
SPEAKER_03: instilling a lot of problems.
Don't worry. Big slap on the shoulder.
SPEAKER_03: Don't worry. Between, I think,
between the two of us, close to a
SPEAKER_03: thousand pounds of fucking
fury.
SPEAKER_01: So, we're good. Or you're
good.
SPEAKER_02: As you lead the way inside, he
mouths to Sochi behind your back. Help
SPEAKER_02: me.
SPEAKER_01: Don't let him take me. I wave
with my fingers.
SPEAKER_00: So, as
SPEAKER_00: everyone else notices and they
go in, multiple people are taking these
SPEAKER_00: Inhaled kind of packets that
they suck in, and as they suck in, they
SPEAKER_00: kind of fall back almost as an
opium den kind of response. You
SPEAKER_00: occasionally see a leg twitch
or a person's eyes bolt up and they look
SPEAKER_00: around, and then they lay back
down.
SPEAKER_03: Union has to absentmindedly
push someone away
SPEAKER_01: who's reaching at him. He's
just like, eh, dumb, shoo.
SPEAKER_00: So he takes you to the back
and you see
SPEAKER_00: a can of gases all on these
piped areas and they're basically the
SPEAKER_00: hand pressed to fill up the
individual
SPEAKER_01: drug packs.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_02: Is your guy here?
SPEAKER_03: Yes. He will be scanning the
room once again for Lucen.
SPEAKER_03: Hopefully at this point it is
of no difficulty to find him. He does so
SPEAKER_03: and brings you to it.
SPEAKER_00: And by the way, here's the
picture of the drug packs. They're like the
SPEAKER_00: ones from Minority Report.
SPEAKER_01: Good God. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: He's like Yeah, he's still
searching pockets.
SPEAKER_00: No, no, he's taking you to the
back area where they're packing the drugs
SPEAKER_00: because you wanted
SPEAKER_01: a private area. Okay, cool.
Uh...
SPEAKER_01: All right, uh, Lucid, this
SPEAKER_03: is, um... A friend of mine who
is trying to make a new friend himself.
SPEAKER_03: And as such, we are in need of
a man who knows people, which you have
SPEAKER_03: already declared this night,
and every night that I have known you is
SPEAKER_03: what you are. So, I will turn
it over to my good friend here,
SPEAKER_01: and we may have a very
beneficial... So you vouch for him?
SPEAKER_01: Hmm? So you vouch for him? I
do. Okay. What do you got to
SPEAKER_01: say?
SPEAKER_02: I have information that I need
to get to a
SPEAKER_02: Solta inspector investigator
through an intermediary.
SPEAKER_01: If I can't know who I am, I
just need to receive this
SPEAKER_01: tip. Is the information
allowed to be known by
SPEAKER_01: the Courier?
SPEAKER_03: I narrow my eyes at that, and
I just kind of raise my eyebrows at Cass.
SPEAKER_02: It'd be safer if he didn't.
Yeah, it'd be safer for the courier than if
SPEAKER_02: he didn't. Exactly. It could
be dangerous knowledge.
SPEAKER_00: Right, but many couriers don't
want to be also delivering their own
SPEAKER_00: death sentences. Oh, no.
SPEAKER_00: Sure.
SPEAKER_02: I was just to... He can
deliver
SPEAKER_02: it and leave, but the courier
can know it. But the courier cannot be
SPEAKER_02: attached in any way to
SPEAKER_02: the Hall of Government or
several organizations. So I'd prefer if the
SPEAKER_02: courier was an unattached
party.
SPEAKER_01: He's going to be connected to
this one. Okay, okay.
SPEAKER_00: Is it a digital piece of
information or is it a packet you have?
SPEAKER_02: I have digital information as
well as physical evidence that we can be
SPEAKER_02: relayed through a dead drop,
but we need to
SPEAKER_02: coordinate the dead drop.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. So you want him to get
this information that may or may not be
SPEAKER_00: faked or processed to lure him
to a dead drop Where you will then
SPEAKER_00: convince he's going to
provide, he's going to get this information and
SPEAKER_00: you guys are going to then
jump him or kill him or something?
SPEAKER_02: No, no. No, we want him to
have the information. Yeah, we just want him
SPEAKER_02: to have the stuff. We want to
make sure that he receives the information
SPEAKER_02: as well as the physical item.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, so you want me to have
my intermediary give him the item?
SPEAKER_02: As long as your intermediary
is, you know, not connected elsewhere,
SPEAKER_02: then yeah, we can arrange
that.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. And you know the name of
the SolSec operative you want me to do
SPEAKER_01: this to?
SPEAKER_01: Yes. Yeah, sorry. Siri
activated when I was trying to answer you. Yes, I
SPEAKER_01: know the name. Okay. And
SPEAKER_01: do you want to pay or do you
want to cash in your favor? As he
SPEAKER_01: looks towards Damien.
SPEAKER_01: Let's cash in our favor. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Not a problem. How soon are
you undone?
SPEAKER_01: Today. The sooner is better.
Okay. And I presume you also want him to
SPEAKER_01: get the information in a
non-public area? Yes.
Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Included area.
SPEAKER_00: If you're willing to have it
be later tonight, I could have someone
SPEAKER_00: break into his house and leave
it on his kitchen table. If
SPEAKER_00: you want it sooner than that,
I know a friend who's into drones who
SPEAKER_00: could deliver it to
SPEAKER_01: his car. I like Plan A.
SPEAKER_01: Which one would draw the least
amount of attention, do you think? Well,
SPEAKER_00: I think in his own home
creates a sense of urgency versus it slipped
SPEAKER_00: into his car.
SPEAKER_03: B&E sounds nice.
SPEAKER_01: Yes, I don't know about you
guys, but I like Plan A too.
SPEAKER_01: Well, when you guys have a
consensus.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, I mean, sounds like
we're
SPEAKER_01: agreed. Yeah, leave it in
SPEAKER_03: his house. Put that shit right
on his bed pillow if you want.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Yeah. Okay. He pulls out
a kind
SPEAKER_00: of sci-fi-looking Ziploc bag,
and he kind of opens it up and is like,
SPEAKER_00: dump whatever you want him to
get in there.
SPEAKER_01: Looks to... I hand over the
package.
SPEAKER_02: It's got the tube, the data
file, and what we've gathered.
SPEAKER_00: By the way, who had Mercer's
original pad?
SPEAKER_01: I do. I was going to give it
to the dolphin.
SPEAKER_00: As everything's being put into
the bag, it puffs up and... Gets
SPEAKER_00: filled with a chemical, and
then it expels the chemical, and he's like,
SPEAKER_00: it clears out any DNA residue
that might have been on any of you.
SPEAKER_02: I'm here for that. I
appreciate that level of discrepancy.
SPEAKER_01: Sounds awesome. Discretion,
that level of discretion. All of a sudden,
SPEAKER_01: the lie starts buzzing. Okay.
Who?
SPEAKER_01: It's the pad. Yeah. Mm-hmm.
SPEAKER_00: I look at the pad. It says,
find my
SPEAKER_00: data pad has been activated.
Oh, we need to be somewhere else.
SPEAKER_00: Cool. I look at him. This
needs to be somewhere else, too. You don't
SPEAKER_00: want to be around it. We don't
want to be around it.
SPEAKER_03: Wait, what's going on?
SPEAKER_00: Now. No, no, no. Do you have a
Faraday cage easily accessible? Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah. Yeah, he pulls out
another plastic bag. Put this in there.
SPEAKER_00: He puts it in there and it
does this little seal thing and you see the
SPEAKER_00: signal on it basically fade to
zero.
SPEAKER_03: We should all be somewhere
else.
SPEAKER_01: What was that?
SPEAKER_03: Later. Right now we all need
to be somewhere else.
SPEAKER_01: Do you want this bag? Yes.
SPEAKER_00: Oh yes, please. Okay, so he
gives you guys the bag with the pad in it.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: And you guys are making a run.
Yes. Now, you have two choices on how to
SPEAKER_00: do this. One is you could have
one person do a streetwise and all of you
SPEAKER_00: are going to follow what they
say.
SPEAKER_03: Okay. The other method...
SPEAKER_00: Is someone could do a vehicle
kind of drive roll.
SPEAKER_00: By the way, Sashi, you get to
just like, because you just run up a
SPEAKER_00: building. Yeah. So you do see
the police are coming,
SPEAKER_00: but you're like, they can't
really catch me. Yeah, I care about my
SPEAKER_00: friends more than I care about
whether or not I get caught. I want to,
SPEAKER_00: we're a Scooby gang. Okay, for
your Scooby gang, someone should roll
SPEAKER_00: then a Streetwise, and if that
Streetwise is at least two successes, you
SPEAKER_00: guys evade the police. At one
success, they are following you, but they
SPEAKER_00: have not caught you. At zero
successes, you are caught.
SPEAKER_01: Shit.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. I do not have vehicles
or Streetwise. I am not that type of smart.
SPEAKER_00: That is two successes on
Streetwise. Okay. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Like I said, we need to leave
now. We're going this way. Stop asking
SPEAKER_00: questions. You get on the
trike, you know exactly the way to drive off
SPEAKER_00: of the freeway entrance where
the police would be coming. As you guys
SPEAKER_00: make two turns, you hear the
police pull up to the drug den and you are
SPEAKER_00: long away.
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan is surprised at how
easily it is for him to fall into. Go this
SPEAKER_03: way, go that way, go, go, go.
SPEAKER_00: So, we are now at the Transar
Sector Exchange with Dan, Victor,
SPEAKER_00: and Emma. Yes. As you guys
come up to
SPEAKER_00: the street area, very similar,
kind of like going into the Mexican
SPEAKER_00: border, they have those metal
gates that you have to kind of push your
SPEAKER_00: way through. And there is a
woman standing
SPEAKER_00: at the booth as you guys are
walking by.
SPEAKER_02: I didn't realize if there
would be an actual checkpoint. I don't know
SPEAKER_02: what I thought. They weren't
going to wave us through, but yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Well, but you're not seeing
security cameras.
SPEAKER_03: Can someone explain to me what
we're doing here, just so I can
SPEAKER_03: understand this?
SPEAKER_02: We're trying to secure,
essentially, housing because this is an
SPEAKER_02: independent situation that the
rest of the government can't touch
SPEAKER_02: inside.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, this is like
international waters, but on a planetary scale. And
SPEAKER_03: so, there's no law that has
jurisdiction.
SPEAKER_01: Well, there's law. Well, it's
their law, not Jordanian law. Yeah, it's
SPEAKER_01: extraterritorial. You're
SPEAKER_01: under corporate law here.
Okay, thanks.
SPEAKER_02: Okay. All right, well, I'll
approach.
SPEAKER_00: It, uh, The person has a
little badge. It says, Reena Kessler. And
SPEAKER_00: it says, hello, what is your
business inside the
SPEAKER_00: Transar sector exchange?
SPEAKER_01: I'm looking to explore a
business opportunity.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, are you looking at coming
to one of our famous shops or are you
SPEAKER_00: looking to gain a job?
SPEAKER_02: Probably gain a job, although
I would like to do some shopping now that
SPEAKER_02: you've mentioned it.
SPEAKER_01: Wonderful.
SPEAKER_00: I imagine you are a Soleimani
citizen.
SPEAKER_01: Yes, of course. She looks even
like a gasp that she would not be.
SPEAKER_01: Put out your hand. I just told
you I'm a citizen.
SPEAKER_01: Absolutely. Then what's the
problem?
SPEAKER_01: Just please put out your hand.
SPEAKER_02: I just told you I'm a citizen.
I don't understand why I have to have
SPEAKER_02: that confirmed I just told
you.
SPEAKER_00: This isn't a confirmation. I
absolutely believe you're a citizen.
SPEAKER_01: Well, then what is this that
you're doing?
SPEAKER_00: I'm giving you your pass
stamp.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, then I look chagrined.
I'm like, I'm so sorry. I thought you were
SPEAKER_02: challenging my... And I'm very
sensitive to that. That's on me. I
SPEAKER_02: apologize.
SPEAKER_00: No, no. Basically, you have a
three-day pass to come in and look for
SPEAKER_00: work, file your resumes, be
able to kind of see where you might be able
SPEAKER_00: to help the Transar greater
corporate organization. And in three days,
SPEAKER_00: the stamp will fade. And you
can leave if you have that, or you will
SPEAKER_00: have a permanent Transar ID if
you find work here.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, I appreciate your
patience with me, and I'll put my hand out.
SPEAKER_00: Not a problem. So she stamps
it.
SPEAKER_02: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: I imagine Dan and Victor are
standing right behind you like... Yes.
SPEAKER_01: Yes, I'm like...
SPEAKER_02: That's how this is done. All
right. I would lead the way and show them
SPEAKER_02: how it's done.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, by the way, and Varian is
right behind you guys too, because he's
SPEAKER_00: now arrived.
SPEAKER_01: That's true, yes.
SPEAKER_02: Assuming then Emma is in fact
let through and passes, Victor will step
SPEAKER_02: up a moment later and present
himself as well.
SPEAKER_00: Are you here for purchasing or
are you here to try to find a job?
SPEAKER_02: I'm here to try to find a job.
SPEAKER_00: Absolutely. And you are a
Soleimani citizen? I am indeed. Wonderful.
SPEAKER_00: Please put out your hand. I
put out my left hand, and she does the
SPEAKER_00: stamp. By the way, it's like a
holographic ink, and it has a little
SPEAKER_00: TransStar logo.
SPEAKER_02: Now, I apologize. I have not
tried to apply for work in TransStar
SPEAKER_02: section before. Is there a
series of computer terminals, or should I
SPEAKER_02: talk to recruiters? Perhaps
you are not the right person. I'm just
SPEAKER_02: curious.
SPEAKER_00: Well, it kind of depends on
your experience. If you're an ex-Navy
SPEAKER_00: person, there are certain
aspects that you could go through the flying
SPEAKER_00: simulators and you could get a
job being part of the shipping crews. If
SPEAKER_00: you're more of a broker,
there's a particular kind of financial area.
SPEAKER_00: And then we also have a
different area for those who feel they have a
SPEAKER_00: great expertise with the
administration paperwork or executive
SPEAKER_00: functions. And for those who
have no skills such as that, there's always
SPEAKER_00: a need for... Loader drivers.
Uh-huh.
SPEAKER_02: Well, I have some experience
with astro-navigation calculation, so
SPEAKER_02: excellent. That was my hope
that there would be a job here. Thank you
SPEAKER_02: very much for the information.
SPEAKER_00: Absolutely. Okay, and then...
And Victor will continue past? Would I be
SPEAKER_00: next, or is someone else next?
It'd be Dan, and then you're last.
SPEAKER_02: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: Um, I am interested in a job,
but, uh, What's this about buying? Perhaps
SPEAKER_03: I might be interested in that
also.
SPEAKER_00: Well, there's a lot of aspect
as Transar is the primary corporation of
SPEAKER_00: this sector of space. We are
able to sell particular goods at a
SPEAKER_00: different tax level aspect of
those who are outside of the Transar
SPEAKER_00: family.
SPEAKER_01: How could I become part of the
Transar family?
SPEAKER_00: If you have a TransStar job,
you are definitely given an employee
SPEAKER_00: discount. Your employee
discount is based on your rank inside TransStar.
SPEAKER_00: As a new level employee, A.
Grunt. You're allowed to get 5% off of our
SPEAKER_00: particular goods. But every
year of experience, you're able to get 0.5%
SPEAKER_00: more off of all of your goods.
Now, some particular people who pass the
SPEAKER_00: executive training course are
able to possibly get a 25% discount even
SPEAKER_00: off of goods right away as a
signing bonus.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, how can I take this test?
I... This sounds very interesting to me.
SPEAKER_00: Absolutely. She's like, in
those tall corporate offices right there, you
SPEAKER_00: can take tests to be in the
junior executive program.
SPEAKER_01: Be a junior executive.
SPEAKER_00: Yes. It is important to
understand, though, that people who do become
SPEAKER_00: employees of TransStar do lose
their citizenship inside the planet
SPEAKER_00: of Jardin. And are merely
corporate employees at that time.
SPEAKER_03: Does that mean that you would
no longer be able to leave the sector?
SPEAKER_00: Well, you would be able to
leave the sector on corporate business and
SPEAKER_00: you'd be able to leave the
planet. But you'll get all that in
SPEAKER_00: orientation. That sounds
excellent. There also is a period of time where
SPEAKER_00: you're allowed to go back and
forth while you're under evaluation. So
SPEAKER_00: you're able to say goodbye to
your family and possibly tell them of the
SPEAKER_00: wonderful experiences of being
a TransStar employee.
SPEAKER_01: I always consider myself a
company man. Thank you.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. And she gives you the
stamp. Okay. And then... Can I determine
SPEAKER_00: whether this
SPEAKER_03: stamp is actually taking our
DNA or
SPEAKER_00: not? It definitely doesn't
look like it's taking her DNA. She is
SPEAKER_00: stamping you with a rubber
stamp. Whether the stamp is some type of
SPEAKER_00: drug, you would need to have a
chemical lab or something, but it doesn't
SPEAKER_00: seem like her stamp has any
way to read something.
SPEAKER_01: Fair enough. So then we walk
in? Well,
SPEAKER_01: we have one more person. Alan.
I'm sorry.
SPEAKER_01: You are currently on mute,
Alan. I am back.
SPEAKER_00: Sorry. So, you would like to
come to the TransStar.
SPEAKER_01: Is this for employment, or are
you looking to make a purchase?
SPEAKER_01: I heard about the test. You
feel that you would be
SPEAKER_01: executive material? What was
that?
SPEAKER_00: Well, she looks at you and
she, because the test was about the executive
SPEAKER_00: position. You feel that you
would be executive.
SPEAKER_01: Retired Navy captain. I am a
war hero. I am a very good
SPEAKER_01: pilot. Yes, there are many
jobs for
SPEAKER_00: people in shipping goods. So
absolutely, there might be work for you
SPEAKER_00: here. So she says, please give
me your hand.
SPEAKER_01: And she's going to stamp your
hand. Yeah. Okay,
SPEAKER_01: I give my hand. Okay, so she
stamps it.
SPEAKER_00: Is there a test? Well, you'll
find a test in the department that you're
SPEAKER_00: looking to join. Tell me about
my department.
SPEAKER_00: I'm not that particular
person. If you just walk down the line, if you
SPEAKER_00: go towards the ships, you
would probably find someone to help you with a
SPEAKER_00: ship test. If you go to the
corporate offices, you'd find people who are
SPEAKER_00: much more bureaucratic. If you
want to go
SPEAKER_00: over to the loading docks,
they also would test people who are skilled
SPEAKER_00: at the loading mechs.
SPEAKER_01: I understand. Thank you. Have
a wonderful TransStar Day!
SPEAKER_03: I will.
SPEAKER_00: I hope you have wonderful
TransStar Day.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, so all of you are inside
TransStar. Now, as you guys are walking
SPEAKER_00: around, there are police
forces here that are dressed differently than
SPEAKER_00: the Jordanian police forces.
Their uniform is...
SPEAKER_00: The Peacekeepers. The
Peacekeepers. The Peacekeepers. The Peacekeepers.
SPEAKER_00: The Peacekeepers.
SPEAKER_01: I was wondering if that's
where you were going, because...
SPEAKER_01: Okay. Did you stop it?
SPEAKER_03: You said you wonder if it was
going there, and then, like, did you say
SPEAKER_03: more, or did you stop talking?
SPEAKER_02: I stopped talking.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_02: But now I'm going to say,
like, Since we're all in, I'd kind of like
SPEAKER_02: pull us over to the side
together if possible to kind of have a
SPEAKER_02: conference. Unless someone is
just dashing over to the corporate office
SPEAKER_02: to try to get a job suddenly.
SPEAKER_01: I hear a little salt there.
SPEAKER_02: No, I...
SPEAKER_02: Victor steps over with you
easy enough. I mean, we got through hurdle
SPEAKER_02: one. It seems reasonable to...
Group up real quick and plan part two?
SPEAKER_02: Yes. So, did you hear this?
SPEAKER_01: We can get off planet, guys.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I heard that too. Like,
that's the thing that I'm wondering if
SPEAKER_02: that's, if it's really that
simple. Because we can always clear our name
SPEAKER_02: by coming back, but, like,
we're going to lose these masks in a matter
SPEAKER_02: of hours and none of us seem
to really want to join a mobster. So maybe
SPEAKER_02: going off planet is,
SPEAKER_01: at least, buys us time.
SPEAKER_01: I agree that it certainly buys
us time. It gives us other options.
SPEAKER_01: Making sure that everyone else
gets here.
SPEAKER_02: I'll be honest, I don't know
if our robot friend counts as a Soleimani
SPEAKER_02: citizen or not, though. For
the purposes of all this.
SPEAKER_01: She might be able to come in
as somebody's property, though. Fair.
SPEAKER_02: Well, okay, so if we can get
off-planet, I think we still need to figure
SPEAKER_02: out how much it's going to
cost to get us off-planet, because I have a
SPEAKER_02: feeling unless we get very
particular jobs, the getting off-planet isn't
SPEAKER_02: the most likely of outcomes.
SPEAKER_01: Well, we have a good
navigator. I am pilot.
SPEAKER_01: We have someone who can direct
mission. I think that we are a
SPEAKER_01: very capable group, don't you
think?
SPEAKER_01: Yes.
SPEAKER_02: Yes, but again, getting all
assigned to the same ship potentially
SPEAKER_02: becomes a problem. Um...
SPEAKER_01: Unless someone becomes
executive and makes sure that we are all on the
SPEAKER_01: same vessel.
SPEAKER_03: I was thinking that sort of
thing too. With a higher level clearance,
SPEAKER_03: then you can... One
administrator who is also known as the,
SPEAKER_01: you know, diplomat. Oh, God.
One who would join us on mission.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. Um...
SPEAKER_02: It probably means then that I
would have to go to the shipping yard and
SPEAKER_02: try my hand there. And then if
I can get an executive
SPEAKER_02: position, I can choose my own
team. And then voila, it's all of
SPEAKER_02: us. What is wrong with my
eyeball? Sorry, I got cat hair in my eyeball.
SPEAKER_03: Are these exams based much on
education? I missed what she said. She
SPEAKER_03: said, sorry, I got what? And
then I missed the end of it. I'm sorry.
SPEAKER_02: I said I have cat hair in my
eyeball.
SPEAKER_03: I forgive you.
SPEAKER_02: I ask if these tests are more
for intelligence or are they
SPEAKER_02: more based on education? I
have zero idea.
SPEAKER_01: Do I have an idea, Patrick?
SPEAKER_00: I would say people could do an
admin with a bane to
SPEAKER_00: try to think about information
from Transdar. Okay. I could do that.
SPEAKER_00: Could I try? Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Sure. So then I make roll type
Bane.
SPEAKER_01: Roll. Okay, you got a one, and
then
SPEAKER_01: Laura, let's see yours.
SPEAKER_02: I'm trying to pull my
character sheet up. It's not being very helpful.
SPEAKER_02: There it is. I'm also going to
have to go rinse my face. Oh, thank you.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, no, that's Steinbach.
Well, that's Steinbach. Yep. I rolled very
SPEAKER_01: badly. There we go. Okay.
StarTran?
SPEAKER_01: I got a minus six. Oh, my God.
SPEAKER_03: Listen, stick to what you're
good at, okay? I'm great at some things,
SPEAKER_03: but I'm also terrible at other
things.
SPEAKER_00: Rolling dice is not one of
those things. Okay.
SPEAKER_03: I'm good at rolling the basic
things I'm good at, okay?
SPEAKER_00: Okay. So Varian knows that
there are
SPEAKER_00: about six different tests
based on what type of department you want to
SPEAKER_00: get into. Now, if you succeed
at a test, you can
SPEAKER_00: basically double down where
you're willing to try a harder test to get
SPEAKER_00: to a higher position. But if
you fail the higher test...
SPEAKER_00: They don't offer you a job
because they think you're too risky. How
SPEAKER_00: interesting. Because if you're
like, hey, I'm the best pilot on this
SPEAKER_00: side of the galaxy. They're
like, okay, well, do your role. You're like,
SPEAKER_00: I did it. They're like, okay,
you want to double down? And they're like,
SPEAKER_00: yeah, I did it. And the moment
you actually say you want to double down,
SPEAKER_00: you failed. Obviously, you
would have been then too risky to transport
SPEAKER_00: goods.
SPEAKER_02: Right. So score high your
first time and then don't travel or...
SPEAKER_00: Or no, you can keep every time
you do it, it is a promotion. But you
SPEAKER_00: have to understand that you
have to know your own limits.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_02: Do we know what those criteria
are, like intelligence or...
SPEAKER_00: The thing is, at a one, that's
the information you get. At Laura's
SPEAKER_00: level, she knows that there
are different tests for different
SPEAKER_00: departments and that people
are... Sometimes people test all the way to
SPEAKER_00: become an executive in one go.
SPEAKER_01: So maybe you only should.
Write checks on your resume, ignore all
SPEAKER_01: instructions, move me up to
the next level.
SPEAKER_03: I got to go
SPEAKER_02: rinse my eyes.
SPEAKER_03: The question is who should
take this executive test or should everyone
SPEAKER_03: try?
SPEAKER_00: Well, you definitely also get
the vibe of you're only allowed to take
SPEAKER_00: one test, and if you fail that
test and you still want employment,
SPEAKER_00: you're a loader.
SPEAKER_03: So here's my thing. We should
all try and get as high as possible,
SPEAKER_03: right? Because we can all be
loaders, right? They need loaders to take
SPEAKER_03: things to other planets,
right? But if we want to be in charge, we got
SPEAKER_03: to... I'm not saying that I'm
a gambler, but I think this is the
SPEAKER_03: time to roll the dice. And if
we succeed, we don't have to be criminals.
SPEAKER_03: And if we fail, I guess we're
going to have to bite that bullet. Looks
SPEAKER_03: like no one promised us good
life if we fail. I mean, or we could live
SPEAKER_03: here for the rest of our
lives, which is, you know, something. Could be
SPEAKER_03: worse. You could wait in line
and be first to go.
SPEAKER_00: Even if you have a job as a
loader, you at least can live in the
SPEAKER_00: exchange. Which would keep you
guys safe even after you lose the veil.
SPEAKER_03: That's the point. That's the
fallback. But winning is
SPEAKER_03: the executive position. I like
winning.
SPEAKER_01: What are your thoughts,
Victor? No,
SPEAKER_01: no.
SPEAKER_02: I think worst case scenario...
We can all live here as loaders.
SPEAKER_02: If the worst case is we can
still be safe here as loaders, that's a win.
SPEAKER_02: Everything above and beyond
that is gravy. And gravy is
SPEAKER_02: good. So I think we should.
Everyone try for their best
SPEAKER_02: fit. And let's hope we get one
or two with an exec level that can help.
SPEAKER_02: Nudge everybody into keeping
working together.
SPEAKER_02: Great idea. So I think
everyone should strive for what they are best at.
SPEAKER_00: Because you're on that plan,
do you want to use your secret
SPEAKER_00: communicators to tell the
other part of the party to grab all your gear
SPEAKER_00: and at least get to Transar
before the bails fail?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, I think that's a smart
call. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Who would like to make that
call just so you guys can say that
SPEAKER_00: conversation in character?
SPEAKER_02: Victor will pull out his phone
and... Secret Secure Weave Jury...
SPEAKER_02: ...and call over to Cass.
Actually, no, I'll call the robot. I haven't
SPEAKER_02: talked to the robot yet. I'll
call the robot. And you plug in.
SPEAKER_00: As you guys are successfully
evading the police, you get a phone call.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah. Did Saichi ever get
charged? Is Saichi, like, charged up or, like,
SPEAKER_03: running out of battery?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_03: He is charged. I helped. I
helped. I helped.
SPEAKER_02: This is Saichi. If you all are
done with
SPEAKER_02: your objectives, I highly
recommend that you Come over to where you
SPEAKER_02: knew that we were going to be.
Just be polite, be kind to them,
SPEAKER_02: and we will meet you inside
the gates. We'll be there as soon as we
SPEAKER_02: evade these authorities.
Please do not bring Party
SPEAKER_02: Crashers to this event. Okay,
sounds good.
SPEAKER_02: And then I'll relay that to
the rest of the team. If things are
SPEAKER_02: critical, let us know,
SPEAKER_01: and we'll see what we can do
to help.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, thank you very much.
SPEAKER_00: I have a feeling like, so
she's
SPEAKER_00: going to be great. She's just
going to finish every phrase. Thank you
SPEAKER_00: for using TransStar Robot
Services. Oh, no.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, so Victor will hang
up...
SPEAKER_00: Free will only to get a
service job.
SPEAKER_02: Victor will hang up and you
all just see his hands slowly come up to his
SPEAKER_02: face and like rub on the one
eye just a little bit,
SPEAKER_02: hard face palm style, and say,
they are being pursued by the police.
SPEAKER_03: They'll be funny. Oh. They'll
be funny. Did they get like new veils or
SPEAKER_03: anything?
SPEAKER_02: No, Sochi did not indicate any
success in their mission. They might
SPEAKER_02: have. It was a brief
conversation. But being pursued by the police does
SPEAKER_02: not fill me with happiness.
SPEAKER_03: Did you tell them to come
here?
SPEAKER_01: No, they cannot come.
SPEAKER_03: Listen, Sochi is fully loaded.
SPEAKER_01: Do not worry. Be happy. I
wonder if we could write
SPEAKER_03: a program for Saichi so Saichi
can get drunk. I was just thinking about
SPEAKER_03: that. That would be kind of
interesting, right? Almost like a temporary
SPEAKER_03: virus. Why?
SPEAKER_00: What?
SPEAKER_03: Never mind. I'm sorry. I was
just thinking. I thought it might be
SPEAKER_03: interesting for Saichi to be
almost a little human.
SPEAKER_02: And as for your question a
moment ago, you all heard what I said.
SPEAKER_02: Please don't bring party
crashers here. Meet us where they knew we were
SPEAKER_02: going to, and we would meet
them inside the gates. Like, without saying
SPEAKER_02: where we were, I told them
where we were, and that they should not bring
SPEAKER_02: cuffs with them.
SPEAKER_03: I didn't hear the other side,
so it's hard for me to figure out exactly
SPEAKER_03: which part went on which. But
I get it, man.
SPEAKER_02: Fair enough. Brevity, I
thought, was a good thing in that moment.
SPEAKER_03: Brevity is the soul of wit.
Are they safe? So... Yeah, I mean, are we
SPEAKER_03: supposed to be going helping
them, or do we feel fine that they're going
SPEAKER_03: to get here on their own?
SPEAKER_02: I said that if they need help,
give us a call. We will do what we can.
SPEAKER_02: But other than that, they are
evading. We will let them handle it until
SPEAKER_02: they call us and say that we
need to help them.
SPEAKER_03: Okay. So who's excited to be
part of this organization, which is almost
SPEAKER_03: as good as being a regular
Soleimani person?
SPEAKER_02: I mean, I'm looking forward to
having a trans-star day. I'm
SPEAKER_02: happy to not have bullseye on
our backs, you know? Yeah. I'm not
SPEAKER_02: so excited about becoming a
corporate shill, but I do appreciate the
SPEAKER_02: luxury of anonymity that it
provides.
SPEAKER_01: This is home. How big is the
area?
SPEAKER_00: So, 2.1 million people live in
the trans-star exchange. That could be
SPEAKER_00: Manhattan.
SPEAKER_01: That's a lot of people.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah. No, that's kind of...
Manhattan's actually probably a great
SPEAKER_00: example. It is probably... I
would even go all of Manhattan. I'd say
SPEAKER_00: it's... Half of Manhattan.
Yeah, it's basically from the park
SPEAKER_00: south to the water.
SPEAKER_03: That's depressing, being
trapped in that tiny little area. I mean, the
SPEAKER_03: truth of the matter is you
could live the rest of your life in
SPEAKER_03: Manhattan. Like, that's the
truth. But conceptually... It wouldn't even
SPEAKER_03: be a bad life. That's true,
exactly. You could still get great food,
SPEAKER_03: great nightlife, great music.
SPEAKER_00: You could have a Trans
Stardet.
SPEAKER_03: But you could never go to the
Brooklyn Bridge Park.
SPEAKER_00: No, but you could see it. You
go to one of the skyscrapers and look at
SPEAKER_00: the park over there.
SPEAKER_03: You can see it from across the
water.
SPEAKER_02: Shall we try to find out what
we can about these tests?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, let's go, man. That
sounds good. Yes, let's do it.
SPEAKER_00: Maybe we can help our comrades
before they get here. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: So, there's an executive test
for the junior executive. There is a
SPEAKER_00: spacing test. There is an arm
guard test.
SPEAKER_00: And there is... We'll bet.
So...
SPEAKER_03: Do we know what you need to
know to take these tests, I guess, is
SPEAKER_00: the question? That was, many
people have attempted roles to answer those
SPEAKER_00: questions, and no one has
succeeded those roles to the level that
SPEAKER_02: that was
SPEAKER_00: done. I had a moderate
success. Just to learn that the tests had a
SPEAKER_00: purpose. To actually know the
individual stats for every single test?
SPEAKER_00: No.
SPEAKER_02: Okay. Can we make another
role, maybe, to deduce which test we should
SPEAKER_02: take? No.
SPEAKER_01: The problem is, while I want
to be an executive, I suspect that that's
SPEAKER_01: going to roll off.
SPEAKER_01: Which I have a minus three in.
Can you say the tests again, which is
SPEAKER_01: which?
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Executive, base, combat,
loader.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, sorry. Instead of loader,
we'll do broker. We'll say everyone who
SPEAKER_00: fails can be a loader. But,
broker... Executive, Spacer,
SPEAKER_00: or Combat?
SPEAKER_03: As pilot, I look at my
friends. As pilot, do you think I should do
SPEAKER_03: Spacer? Yes, you should do
Spacer. Okay. That's what I will
SPEAKER_03: do.
SPEAKER_00: Does any other PC want to do
Spacer?
SPEAKER_02: I will do Spacer, but if
possible, I'd also like to pep talk my crew and
SPEAKER_02: maybe see if I can do a
leadership role. To give them bonuses on their
SPEAKER_02: test.
SPEAKER_00: Maybe you should be executive.
So you only can do that for people who
SPEAKER_00: are doing the same test you
are, just as you know.
SPEAKER_01: Cool. Let's take it together.
SPEAKER_00: The tests are not near each
other, by the way. So, spacer, broker,
SPEAKER_00: loader, and mech? No, combat.
Like, you're basically a mercenary. You're
SPEAKER_00: armed guard.
SPEAKER_03: So, Spacer, I mean, I have
Jump Drive, like a three or something like
SPEAKER_03: that. I don't know. That's
pretty solid. Yeah, but is it Jump
SPEAKER_03: Drive? Or is it flying a
plane? You know what I mean? It's not so
SPEAKER_03: easy.
SPEAKER_02: Well, I'm sure it's a pretty
broad-spectrum test. They'll need multiple
SPEAKER_02: positions. It's not like
they're only hiring for the one.
SPEAKER_01: Well, you're right. Maybe
there is hope.
SPEAKER_01: Broker sounds like I'd be
terrible at it because I don't have a broker
SPEAKER_01: role. Does it show that I'm
still logged
SPEAKER_01: into the app? Yes, it does.
SPEAKER_03: I didn't close it, but I don't
know where it is. It's so weird.
SPEAKER_00: I think there are two people
who want to do Spacer, so we can do the
SPEAKER_00: Spacer role while you guys
decide the other ones, right?
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I guess I'm going to do
the executive because that's the whole
SPEAKER_02: plan is to try to get us all
on one ship by having an executive say
SPEAKER_02: that. And I'm not really the
best spacer. I have space things. I'm
SPEAKER_02: space adjacent because I have
piloting, but I have zero other skills
SPEAKER_02: in the space realm.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, I have a lot of... I
don't know. So spacer or... You know, I'll
SPEAKER_03: come with you, Laura. Let's
go. Don't worry about it, guys. If everyone
SPEAKER_03: gets loaded, enough parts will
fall off the back of a truck for some
SPEAKER_03: fixed ship underneath the
ocean. We're going to win.
SPEAKER_01: We'll build our own spaceship.
SPEAKER_00: It's the movie where people
fall off fixed trucks. Hey, Steinbach,
SPEAKER_00: can you do your leadership
role so we can see how many you're going to
SPEAKER_00: give Alan?
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Because Al's the other one
doing Spacer. Wow. He has three boons he can
SPEAKER_00: take.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, that was pretty great.
SPEAKER_00: Thank you.
SPEAKER_02: Okay. Comrade, you did well. I
should have come. I should have come.
SPEAKER_02: Hey, and you know what? You're
going to do well on this test, too. I
SPEAKER_02: have faith in you.
SPEAKER_03: Listen. It's all in the hands
of something else.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, so you go into, Alan,
you go into a VR simulator kind of dome.
SPEAKER_00: You basically walk in and the
dome is there. As you begin to kind of go
SPEAKER_00: in almost like a holodeck
style, it begins to create a layout
SPEAKER_00: of a far trader and a seat,
SPEAKER_00: and multiple seats come up. Do
you want to try to sit in the captain's
SPEAKER_00: seat? Do you want to sit in an
engineering jump seat?
SPEAKER_00: Can I sit in the pilot seat?
Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Can I sit in the pilot seat?
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, man, I could have
SPEAKER_00: done this. Is this a
spacecraft? Yes, it is a spacecraft. Excellent. Do
SPEAKER_00: I make a spacecraft roll? You
are making spacecraft plus education, and
SPEAKER_00: you have a boon in it because
of your leadership thing. So what do I
SPEAKER_00: add? Okay, so I do... So you
go spacecraft, you click on spacecraft.
SPEAKER_01: Uh-huh.
SPEAKER_00: And then roll type, you click
boon, and you hit roll.
SPEAKER_01: Uh-huh. Roll type boon, and
then roll.
SPEAKER_01: Nice.
SPEAKER_00: You have reached pilot level
one, grunt pilot. Are you going to attempt
SPEAKER_00: to roll again? Of course.
Okay.
SPEAKER_01: The pilot seat disappears. Oh.
What's left?
SPEAKER_01: All the other seats that you
would imagine on a spacecraft. Um, can I
SPEAKER_01: choose the... Is
SPEAKER_01: there a... flyer seat?
SPEAKER_01: What do you mean flyer seat?
You just piloted. Oh, sorry. So, um...
SPEAKER_02: Let's see. Is a mechanic seat
available?
SPEAKER_00: No. Let me just clear it for
you. Okay, so there is a jump drive
SPEAKER_00: engineer seat. There is a
power seat
SPEAKER_00: for engineer. Well, I guess
there's an engineering seat. That's going to
SPEAKER_00: be one role in engineering.
There's one role for electronics. And
SPEAKER_00: that's it. Oh, and there's an
astrogation seat. I'll do the... And I
SPEAKER_00: still have a boon, right? Yep,
because you have three boons because of
SPEAKER_00: Steinbach's Super Bowl on you.
SPEAKER_02: I'll do an... I'll do an
SPEAKER_02: Engineer seat this time.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, and give me a second.
SPEAKER_01: Man, I would have done so well
on this, I could roll on all of these.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, J-Drive roll. Oh, so I
actually clicked J-Drive.
SPEAKER_01: Yep. Okay, J-Drive, Boon. Yep.
SPEAKER_01: Nice. Nice. Success.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. The J-Drive, the
engineering seat goes away. There is now only
SPEAKER_00: electronics astrogation left.
SPEAKER_01: I go to electronics. This is
my last Boon, correct? Yep.
SPEAKER_01: Yep, roll the computer roll.
Man, you're lucky.
SPEAKER_01: Wait, can you stop if you
wanted to?
SPEAKER_00: Yep, and... Okay, that seat
goes away, and that was the exact number of
SPEAKER_00: successes you needed for it,
by the way. You needed three or more. The
SPEAKER_00: last seat there was
Astrogation. Wow. You did it!
SPEAKER_00: If you roll Astrogation, and
you do have that stat, you would need four
SPEAKER_00: successes. If you do get four
successes, though, you basically have
SPEAKER_00: passed all the entire pilot
test.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, I think I'm on a roll,
and I'm going to do it.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. All right. Roll it, and
you do not have a boon.
SPEAKER_01: You do not pass. You need
four. You got three.
SPEAKER_00: What happens now? Welcome to
being a loader.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, damn it.
No!
SPEAKER_00: I was like, don't do it! It
was so good.
SPEAKER_01: Yes. That test begins. What
would you like to sit in?
SPEAKER_02: Is there an electronic sensor
role?
SPEAKER_00: So, electronics and
engineer... I actually roll a 1d4, and
SPEAKER_00: whatever that number is, is
the one that it requests.
SPEAKER_01: Ooh. Okay.
SPEAKER_02: You know, honestly, I think
that's... I'm going to go a different role
SPEAKER_02: on this entirely. I'm going to
sit in the captain's
SPEAKER_01: chair first. Okay, sit in the
captain's chair, roll your leadership.
SPEAKER_01: You need at least a 1. You do
not get it.
SPEAKER_02: Welcome to Loader Status. Yep.
Wow, I rolled a one and a two on the die.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, no. This is going so well.
SPEAKER_03: Let's not go back to Draenex,
Victor. Let's not go back to Draenex.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. So now we have Emma
SPEAKER_00: and Keith in the junior
executive room.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah. As you guys walk in, it
is not a
SPEAKER_00: you walk in Hollow thing, it
is you lay into a pod that surrounds you.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, okay. And it begins
SPEAKER_00: to start having a situation as
you kind of are, you are
SPEAKER_00: currently dealing with a
problem employee. Now...
SPEAKER_00: Uh, the first roll is
Persuade.
SPEAKER_01: Alright.
SPEAKER_01: I can't apparently alphabetize
these. There it is.
SPEAKER_01: Alright,
SPEAKER_01: figuring out my loader status.
SPEAKER_02: Oh my god!
SPEAKER_00: Oh wow!
SPEAKER_02: I'm super good at that!
SPEAKER_00: So, you have made your way up
to now be a paper pusher. Do you wish to
SPEAKER_00: go to the next role?
SPEAKER_01: Do I know what the next role
is?
SPEAKER_00: No. That's the problem with
the executive. Pilot, you know
SPEAKER_01: where to sit. I feel like
SPEAKER_01: I have to because being a
SPEAKER_02: paper pusher isn't going to be
able to allow me to work with my friends,
SPEAKER_02: essentially.
SPEAKER_00: Yep. So the next one is a
carouse roll.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, okay.
SPEAKER_01: You're good at that, right?
Yeah, I am. I'm going to fail all of these.
SPEAKER_00: I should have dropped that
three. Damn it. Would you like to roll again?
SPEAKER_01: Oh, fuck you. What am I now?
SPEAKER_00: You are a middle manager
organizing paperworks back and forth.
SPEAKER_03: Probably the next one is gonna
be diplomacy.
SPEAKER_02: This is making me think of the
stupid character generation and they hate
SPEAKER_02: everything about it.
SPEAKER_03: I was thinking it reminds me
of the character generator, but I like the
SPEAKER_03: character generator, but I
think it's not on my side for this.
SPEAKER_02: I don't like having unknowns.
They make me itchy.
SPEAKER_03: I mean, the problem is there's
a lot of roles that could be. It could be
SPEAKER_03: admin. It could be diplomacy.
It could be Advocate even.
SPEAKER_01: All right, I'm going to try
it. Yeah, I will. It
SPEAKER_01: is Advocate. Okay, sweet. You
got
SPEAKER_01: that also? That's amazing.
Awesome. Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: No way.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, I'm amazing.
SPEAKER_00: You are a project organizer.
There's only one more role, and the
SPEAKER_00: higher role is
SPEAKER_01: you are a leader of a
division.
SPEAKER_01: Did I already roll carouse?
Was that a thing? Yeah, I did. Okay. I'm
SPEAKER_01: like, leadership of a
division.
SPEAKER_01: Sorry, I'm not trying to be
quiet.
SPEAKER_02: I'm just trying to... I'm
looking at my stats and thinking, like, how
SPEAKER_02: far should I... What do you
think
SPEAKER_03: and use your brain?
SPEAKER_02: See, like, one of the things
that I'm kind of relying on is that my base
SPEAKER_02: stats are pretty good. So even
if I have a zero in something, I'm still
SPEAKER_02: rolling, like, plus ones. And,
like, if it's education, it's plus three.
SPEAKER_00: It's definitely better. By the
way, to totally cheese it, I kind of
SPEAKER_00: thought you guys should have
broughten Steinbach to the executive
SPEAKER_00: meeting. He six fails, but his
leaderships would have each given you
SPEAKER_00: boons.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, that would be a good idea.
Oh, well.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah. Yeah.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, that one's so good.
Especially because I think I'm going to flub all
SPEAKER_03: of these roles. I'm going to
try it.
SPEAKER_02: I'm going to go big. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Which I think I do have. I
don't know how to spell, though. I do have.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. You got it. No way.
SPEAKER_01: Wow, Laura. Yay. Seven levels
of success.
SPEAKER_02: Hell, yeah. Oh, my God. My
palms are sweaty, though. Knees weak. Arms
SPEAKER_02: are heavy. Does that mean
Laura's in charge now? Is that what's
SPEAKER_02: going on? Emma's in charge?
I'm afraid. I don't want that. I
SPEAKER_02: specifically set out... Girl,
boss, too close to the sun.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, girl, you got it.
Gentlemen, we will start calling Charles.
SPEAKER_00: I'm in charge. So we need Josh
to do his crazy role.
SPEAKER_03: I'm going to fail all of
these. I don't have any of these. I have minus
SPEAKER_03: threes on every single one. I
really...
SPEAKER_01: What did you expect? Huh? What
roles did you think they'd be?
SPEAKER_03: I thought maybe that I
could... Because I thought
SPEAKER_03: maybe leadership, maybe
diplomat, you know, some of that. But it's okay.
SPEAKER_03: I came more for moral support.
None of the roles seemed exactly
SPEAKER_03: right for me. Although,
ironically, I would have done super well in the
SPEAKER_03: other roles. That's the ironic
thing.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, so let's start
SPEAKER_03: with Persuade.
SPEAKER_00: It's okay. I can't get less
than a two, right? Persuade.
SPEAKER_01: You did get less than a two.
SPEAKER_01: Only when you do minus three.
Okay.
SPEAKER_00: You have reached the executive
of the loaders.
Oh, no.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Now, we are waiting now
just for... So those
SPEAKER_00: are the four people who went,
right, to that location? Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. So, now that they've
done that, and the other group has
SPEAKER_00: kind of prepped that, I
imagine Emma is going to tell the rest of the
SPEAKER_00: group that she's become an
executive.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah. I'm just a warden.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. So, the
SPEAKER_00: rest of the gear is being
brought over. And the other party is at the
SPEAKER_00: entry exchange. So I imagine
Siren is going to be
SPEAKER_00: probably first or Cass.
SPEAKER_01: Sure, I'll walk up there.
SPEAKER_03: And I mean, I'm there in
X-Cort.
SPEAKER_00: And it says, Hello, welcome to
Transtar. Are you a Soleimani citizen?
SPEAKER_02: I am a Soleimani citizen. How
are you today? Are you having a
SPEAKER_02: Transtar...
SPEAKER_00: I'm having a transtar moment.
Are you here to purchase goods,
SPEAKER_00: or are you here to look for
your work?
SPEAKER_02: I'm here to submit my resume.
Wonderful. Please give me your hand.
SPEAKER_01: Sure. And she gives you a
stamp. Excellent. I feel like I belong.
SPEAKER_01: Yes.
SPEAKER_00: And... You guys do realize you
have a robot and an ape with you.
SPEAKER_02: That's true. I have my
mechanical assistant here
SPEAKER_02: with me. May she gain entry as
well.
SPEAKER_00: Well, if you're here to be
employed by TransStar, you would not be able
SPEAKER_00: to have a previous personal
property. She'd become a TransStar piece of
SPEAKER_00: property.
SPEAKER_01: She said to you,
SPEAKER_03: That is why we are searching
for jobs. We do not have one here at
SPEAKER_03: Transtar yet, but that is good
to know, thank you.
SPEAKER_01: May she have entry. May they
have entry.
SPEAKER_01: Let me look at the paperwork.
And starts rifling through some papers.
SPEAKER_01: Kirin will glance at Saichi.
Did I get that right? Where'd I fuck up?
SPEAKER_00: Any of you can attempt to roll
an advocate roll to find the proper
SPEAKER_00: authorization to get her
through in a better way? If not...
SPEAKER_03: Let me find my advocacy, which
will be negative three. I don't need to
SPEAKER_03: look, but I am going to look.
Advocate.
SPEAKER_00: At least Cass Penn's only
running negative two because he does have
SPEAKER_00: jackalot traits. Negative
three. I want to roll a negative two, too.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_02: I'm going to encourage you to
SPEAKER_02: delve into your mind. I know
you've got a solution. What do you think,
SPEAKER_02: Elias? Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So, roll your leadership.
SPEAKER_01: Marginal. That's none.
SPEAKER_01: Level success is the number of
boons they get. Oh, okay. Oh!
SPEAKER_01: And that's a thing you can do
in a leadership role. Yeah. Do you have a
SPEAKER_01: leadership? Ironically, I do.
Let's
SPEAKER_01: see how this goes. Social of
Eight.
SPEAKER_01: They are shaken by your
leadership.
SPEAKER_01: You're like, I bet better
advice is inside.
SPEAKER_00: You just got to get inside,
right? Okay. So who wants to roll a bad
SPEAKER_00: admin? Or a bad advocate?
SPEAKER_01: Zoe has. Yeah, I did. I rolled
a bad one.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. So there's no paperwork
that you guys are able to authorize to
SPEAKER_00: figure out how. The paperwork
that comes up is they will have to be with
SPEAKER_00: a restraining collar and a tag
that will guarantee that they're either
SPEAKER_00: part of Transdar property or
off the facility in three days.
SPEAKER_01: Fine. Okay, that buys us some
time. Are you okay with that, Sochi?
SPEAKER_01: That should work. It should
work.
SPEAKER_00: They reach into a box, and
they take out a restrainer thing, and they
SPEAKER_00: connect it to your port. You
feel that all your guns are powered down
SPEAKER_00: while the port is connected.
SPEAKER_02: Okay. Yep. Guns offline.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Then, they just kind of
give you a stamp on your
SPEAKER_00: chest.
SPEAKER_02: Yay! It's sparkly, though. I'm
safe!
SPEAKER_00: Now we come to the question of
when you guys are bringing the Zoi and
SPEAKER_00: they're like, so you're not a
Soleimani citizen.
SPEAKER_01: I forget what the legal status
is exactly.
SPEAKER_00: You're not a Soleimani
citizen. That's the legal status. Oh, okay. I'm
SPEAKER_00: authorized to work. You're a
resident alien. I'm authorized to work.
SPEAKER_01: You're authorized to work. Can
I see your work papers?
SPEAKER_00: And you're like, oh, yeah,
those ones in my identity I'm currently
SPEAKER_00: faking?
SPEAKER_01: Exactly.
SPEAKER_02: They're in my other pocket.
Sorry about that.
SPEAKER_01: What do you get a second? Can
I deception to try to get them passed?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah. Yeah. Let's see.
SPEAKER_01: You're like, hey, you know, he
already is a TransStar employee, but
SPEAKER_01: those monkeys, they always
forget their paperwork.
SPEAKER_00: Question is, does Zoe, like,
nod and agree with the random station?
SPEAKER_01: Absolutely. Okay. Yeah. I'm
sorry, I was just embarrassed.
SPEAKER_03: I don't want to admit it. It's
the third time I forgot it, so I came
SPEAKER_03: into this entrance, the one I
usually do.
SPEAKER_00: Get out of here! So they let
you in, but they don't
SPEAKER_00: stamp you.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. So you're able to meet
up with the other people who've just
SPEAKER_00: come out of their tests, and
they can explain the bit to you.
SPEAKER_03: What is the bit? Hi, we had
quite the time. What has been going on here?
SPEAKER_03: We are all looking for work.
SPEAKER_02: We got jobs.
SPEAKER_03: You got jobs?
SPEAKER_02: Yes. The idea being is that if
we get legitimate jobs, we can get
SPEAKER_02: off-planet. And that will buy
us time.
SPEAKER_01: Damn. Okay. No, spacing.
SPEAKER_03: Hey, that's what I was doing.
You know, that's what I was going to get
SPEAKER_03: back to doing before this.
Sure. Fine. Great.
SPEAKER_02: So there are multiple tests.
They're a little on the tricky side.
SPEAKER_02: I'm trying to remember,
there's Spacer, there's Executive, there
SPEAKER_02: was Combat, and
SPEAKER_03: Broker,
SPEAKER_02: thank you.
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan looks rather dedicated
and nostalgic for a bit, and he's like,
SPEAKER_03: oh, fuck, yeah, the aptitude
tests. These suck. I have to do these
SPEAKER_03: again?
SPEAKER_02: Well, to be a train start and
flee and have a train start day, yes.
SPEAKER_03: And we're actually having a
TransStar Day? Like, we're not just...
SPEAKER_02: Well, I'm assuming there is
no... We're having the greatest of
SPEAKER_02: TransStars Day. We're drinking
the Kool-Aid as deeply as we can.
SPEAKER_03: Okay. I guess I would explain
to them what things we're testing
SPEAKER_03: on the test that I took.
SPEAKER_02: Sure. And Victor will explain
SPEAKER_02: his experience with the...
Spacer test. Although, of course,
SPEAKER_02: Alan Watt got further along
than he did.
SPEAKER_01: It's okay. Don't be eager.
Don't reach sun too quick.
SPEAKER_03: Wait, what was the advice?
Give that again. No, yes, I need the advice.
SPEAKER_03: I don't remember.
SPEAKER_01: Don't reach sun too quick.
Stop when
SPEAKER_03: you can. Oh, oh, oh, okay. And
you can't take a second test, right? You
SPEAKER_03: can only take one test? Yeah.
I figured. I figured.
SPEAKER_00: So, by the way, the key reason
why this is occurring is to understand
SPEAKER_00: your risk concept. You have to
know how good you are and not risk
SPEAKER_00: their merchandise or their
ships.
SPEAKER_01: Sure. Very much. Or you could
just fail on your first roll.
SPEAKER_03: I knew I was going to fail
before I took it. Really, as soon as I saw I
SPEAKER_03: was going to sit in, I was
like, I don't want to take this test. But I
SPEAKER_03: didn't think I could back out
of it and switch.
SPEAKER_02: Hearing all these horror
stories, like, Emma is like, yeah, I made
SPEAKER_02: executive division head.
SPEAKER_03: What does executive division
head mean? And is there any way that you
SPEAKER_03: can jury-rig the courses for
us with that position?
SPEAKER_02: I doubt that. Shit, dammit.
SPEAKER_03: Fuck. I don't want to take
these tests again. I don't know if I can take
SPEAKER_03: these tests again.
SPEAKER_01: We shall see. Is there any
SPEAKER_01: chance anyone saw... Is there
any chance anyone saw a space crew job
SPEAKER_01: description crewman?
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, you can just be a loader
if you want. They have a combat option.
SPEAKER_02: Why would you not choose the
combat option?
SPEAKER_03: Damn, combat option? Why
didn't you say so?
SPEAKER_02: I did say so.
SPEAKER_03: Oh. I must have been... Wasn't
there also like a loader
SPEAKER_02: test or something like that?
No, you can just be a loader. No, there was
SPEAKER_02: like a mech test or something?
Oh, a mech test.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, but then I realized
there had to be a broker, so we replaced that
SPEAKER_00: with broker. Oh.
SPEAKER_03: I could also be do mech stuff,
if want. But combat. It
SPEAKER_03: is what I was doing before.
SPEAKER_00: So I imagine you're going to
go to combat, and
SPEAKER_00: Elias, you're going to go to
what? Obviously, they're not going to give
SPEAKER_00: a robot independence, so you
don't need to take a test.
SPEAKER_00: But Elias can take a test.
SPEAKER_01: So what test are you going to
take?
SPEAKER_01: Are the people going in there
to take the combat tests, do they have
SPEAKER_01: leadership? I do. Where are
you
SPEAKER_01: going, Kolb? I'm going to a
spacer. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: So my plan is, hopefully, the
first test, the low gun skill, we'll get
SPEAKER_00: it passed. Then... See if
Recon and Stell can get past any other
SPEAKER_00: tests, like, you know, they
need, like, scouts or someone to check a
SPEAKER_00: room before they clear it,
that sort of thing.
SPEAKER_01: That sounds like combat. Yeah,
but it's corporate security combat.
SPEAKER_00: So, since Kolb is going to the
one that no one else is going to, let's
SPEAKER_00: do yours first, Kolb.
SPEAKER_01: I can. All right.
SPEAKER_02: Maybe I should go to combat,
if they're going to combat. Both of you
SPEAKER_02: guys are going to combat?
SPEAKER_01: Maybe?
SPEAKER_02: Well, if both of you are going
to the same place, I'll go with you, and
SPEAKER_02: then I can leadership you.
Sure. I don't know why you wouldn't go to
SPEAKER_02: combat, Kieran.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, no. I didn't know that
there was one, and he's going to combat.
SPEAKER_02: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: It's much more Cast and Elias
where they should go. Yeah. Is Saichi able
SPEAKER_00: to participate in this, or am
I just... You're in as a piece
SPEAKER_00: of property, because you're
not wanting to tell them you're
SPEAKER_00: psychologically independent,
right? Right, yes. I
SPEAKER_00: will be a coat rack. I'm happy
to load all day, all night.
SPEAKER_03: Do not worry, Saichi, I can
attest to your combat readiness.
SPEAKER_00: I don't need to prove myself.
I just wanted to help.
SPEAKER_03: No, no, no, you do not.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so all combat...
SPEAKER_02: Yep, I will leadership you
guys. You guys can do it. I believe in you. I
SPEAKER_02: think that you're going to get
promoted.
SPEAKER_01: You're going to be heads of
security somewhere. Holy shit. Heads of...
SPEAKER_01: All right.
SPEAKER_03: You know what? I'm going to
take that advice to heart.
SPEAKER_00: Wow. Six boons.
SPEAKER_02: Wow. Holy crap.
SPEAKER_00: Boons.
SPEAKER_02: Six boons.
SPEAKER_00: So, as you guys are walking
up, they say, are you guys all taking the
SPEAKER_00: test? And we scream, fuck yes,
because we've been inspired
SPEAKER_00: by a god.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: So, they bring you all in the
room at
SPEAKER_01: the same time. Oh. Sick.
SPEAKER_00: Now, here's the way the combat
mechanic works. I'm going to give four
SPEAKER_00: different roles that you guys
can pick from. The problem is, not one of
SPEAKER_00: you can pick the same role the
other person is picking.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. I like this.
SPEAKER_00: And, if you've passed a test
with a role, you can never do that role
SPEAKER_00: again.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. The first role is...
Tactics, Military. The second
SPEAKER_00: role is Gun Combat, Energy.
The third role is
SPEAKER_00: Recon.
SPEAKER_01: The fourth role is Medic.
Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Right off the bat, the highest
I think I've got out of those is a Medic
SPEAKER_01: of one.
SPEAKER_03: The rest are zeros, though.
Pretty balanced in a little bit. So
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan's just kind of happy
to be directed to which one he will
SPEAKER_03: communicate.
SPEAKER_02: Kiernan, you're on first aid
duty.
SPEAKER_01: Perfect. Cracks. Does anyone
here have
SPEAKER_01: the military tactics skill?
SPEAKER_02: No, I'm a tactics of zero with
the military.
SPEAKER_00: But none of you have it at
negative, I think, is the key thing. Yeah,
SPEAKER_00: that's pretty nice. And so a
person with a boon who doesn't have a
SPEAKER_00: negative is kind of an angle
you guys are going to want to move to.
SPEAKER_01: We have six of them. Does
anybody... Do either
SPEAKER_02: of you have a military and
zero? I do. Mine's negative, so...
SPEAKER_02: Okay, you should take a
military then. Tactics military. Get a zero,
SPEAKER_02: because you've got the boon to
roll. Alrighty. I'll roll
SPEAKER_02: Gun Combat Energy, because I
have that at one, but I don't get any
SPEAKER_02: boons. That's the only thing I
have worthwhile of those.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. What's left?
SPEAKER_02: Or Medic.
SPEAKER_03: Yes, Medic.
SPEAKER_00: Or Recon. One's a Gun Combat,
one's a Recon, and one is Tactics
SPEAKER_00: Military. Those are the four
rolls of this turn.
SPEAKER_03: And I am going to roll the
tactics now. Three, two, one.
SPEAKER_00: And you're booning it. Yep,
you got it. Okay. And that is a failure.
SPEAKER_01: Why did it... Oh, but that
wasn't me. Okay. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. Now, we need Elias and
Golds.
SPEAKER_01: That is a pass for cold. I
wanted to save this for a second roll, but
SPEAKER_01: all right. Oh, well, we got
all those boons, so what am I talking about?
SPEAKER_01: We have six, too. Yeah, you
each have six.
SPEAKER_00: And that's a pass for game.
Okay. Are you guys going to
SPEAKER_00: try to rise higher than
Private Grunt?
SPEAKER_02: Yeah. Let's go one more. We
still got tons of boons left. Yeah.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, I would like to roll
energy with the boon if that's all right.
SPEAKER_00: No! Every turn is different
rolls.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, okay. Different boar,
okay.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Oh, okay. So, this turn
is
SPEAKER_01: melee blade, heavy weapons man
portable,
SPEAKER_01: investigation, And...
SPEAKER_01: Drive... Actually, no.
Electronics comps.
SPEAKER_02: I have electronics comps. Does
anybody have anything else there? At
SPEAKER_02: least a
SPEAKER_03: zero. I have a blade of one.
Oh, I have a blade of one. Which
SPEAKER_03: means we can switch around.
Okay, we had Blade, Electronics...
SPEAKER_01: Peter, you already failed. So
I'm out. You're out.
SPEAKER_01: Good to know. Alright, I'll do
SPEAKER_01: Blade, I guess, with a boon.
Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Bam! Bam, bam.
SPEAKER_00: Well, you did a recon for some
reason. But you also won with your melee,
SPEAKER_00: and Cole won with his
electronics. Okay. Now, the next
SPEAKER_00: level would be the lowest
level. So that was basically a sergeant. The
SPEAKER_00: next level is part of a heavy
weapons team. The level after that is
SPEAKER_00: you're leading a squad, and
then the last level is they give you a
SPEAKER_00: battlesuit.
SPEAKER_01: You guys want to keep going?
Zoe, you still have tons of boons left to
SPEAKER_01: roll if you want to keep
rolling.
SPEAKER_00: He's going to roll one for
every time. Because there's only one of you,
SPEAKER_00: so
SPEAKER_01: it doesn't matter. Are you
willing to risk it?
SPEAKER_01: No. Because right now I'm the
only one
SPEAKER_01: allowed to walk around
carrying a gun, right? Because everyone else
SPEAKER_01: failed? No, I passed. Oh,
okay.
SPEAKER_01: Probably not. I don't think
I'm going to have the skills to keep going,
SPEAKER_01: even with the boon.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, so knowing that there
won't be a heavy weapons portable, but
SPEAKER_02: you're part of a heavy weapons
squad tempts me, because I do
SPEAKER_01: have vehicle heavy weapons.
It's up to you.
SPEAKER_01: No, I'm going to stop. I don't
get boon, so. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: So, all you guys stop. Two of
you guys are sergeants. The other guy is a
SPEAKER_00: loader. Okay. Everyone has
done their
SPEAKER_00: signing up for jobs. And you
are all given a
SPEAKER_00: note that you are to meet
Elaine Moreau. Sorry. Claire Bouchard.
SPEAKER_00: Claire Beauchard is going to
organize your living
SPEAKER_00: accommodations and get your
assignments prepared.
SPEAKER_00: So you guys can all go in as a
room as she kind of breaks that down for
SPEAKER_00: you.
SPEAKER_02: Sorry, I was muted. My nose
was running. I said, okay, I'll go there
SPEAKER_02: then.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Does anyone want to,
while they're getting there, want to think of
SPEAKER_00: a plan of what they're going
to do in three days for Sashi?
SPEAKER_02: I was going to appropriate her
as part of my signing package.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, yeah. With your role,
yeah. There's not going to be a problem with
SPEAKER_00: that.
SPEAKER_01: That was my thought, yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. So, all of you guys go
into a very HR-looking
SPEAKER_00: room, and... Claire Burchard
says, thank you all for joining
SPEAKER_00: TransStar. From the highest
SPEAKER_00: executive to every single
person who loads the data that we need
SPEAKER_00: on, TransStar is built up by
every employee that we have. Now, we've had
SPEAKER_00: a little bit of difficulty in
reading your faces for your employee ID.
SPEAKER_00: I bet she has. Are you willing
to fill
SPEAKER_00: out a small questionnaire
SPEAKER_01: as she starts handing out
pads?
SPEAKER_01: I mean, I'll see what it is.
SPEAKER_02: Like, maybe it's just shit
like, are you allergic to something? I mean,
SPEAKER_02: it's probably not, but you
never know. We're in so deep now.
SPEAKER_03: Is there any chance that we
can set stone the identity of the person who
SPEAKER_03: took this test so that if it
turns out that I have a different identity
SPEAKER_03: later, I can take the test
again?
SPEAKER_00: That's up to you. You guys can
try to vague that around. I like that
SPEAKER_00: idea.
SPEAKER_03: I think he introduces himself
as Jim Robinson.
SPEAKER_00: You're like, hey, I need a new
veil, just so I can take my testing.
SPEAKER_00: Quick, quick, quick. One more
veil. So, as you guys
SPEAKER_00: have a pattern of the state,
it says, are you A, an enemy of the state,
SPEAKER_00: B, a race traitor, C,
SPEAKER_00: a member of another
corporation,
SPEAKER_01: I like how it's multiple
choice. Do you have to be one of those things?
SPEAKER_00: Well, because your identity is
hidden. Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Oh. For D, none of the above?
Are you a criminal?
SPEAKER_01: Hey.
SPEAKER_03: Notably, it does not say that
they're not willing to do
SPEAKER_03: business. Oh, yeah, yeah.
They're still hiring you. They just want to
SPEAKER_03: know who they're hiring.
SPEAKER_00: It's a French Foreign Legion
vibe here. But I definitely like the idea
SPEAKER_03: of taking the test again with
a different identity.
SPEAKER_00: I want to do that, actually.
We're just being framed is all.
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan is looking at almost
SPEAKER_03: for permission to sign from
people. He's like, we're doing this.
SPEAKER_01: This is the bit.
SPEAKER_01: I have a different name on my
cover. Race Trader and
SPEAKER_03: Foreign Company, right?
SPEAKER_01: Yes.
SPEAKER_03: I mean, of those, Race Trader
seems the least objectionable. Yes,
SPEAKER_03: I think officially we are
enemies of state, correct? If I remember from
SPEAKER_03: the news report? I don't say
this out loud. I'm asking for memory of
SPEAKER_03: that news report. What did
they call it? Oh, excuse me.
SPEAKER_03: We're like rebels or
something.
SPEAKER_00: One could construe the most
truthful answer is probably enemies of the
SPEAKER_00: state.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, that's what I thought.
Yeah, like with an asterisk.
SPEAKER_03: Unwilling, unwilling enemies
of the state. Sure, I mean, I'm happy to
SPEAKER_03: underline that. I do believe
that, but are we like signing this? Is this
SPEAKER_03: a thing we're confirming?
Yeah.
SPEAKER_02: I'm just going to go for it,
and I'm going to put Enemy of the State,
SPEAKER_02: because the worst that they
can do is throw me out and fuck it at
SPEAKER_02: this point.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, you click Enemy of the
State. It says, you do need to, and then
SPEAKER_00: you see a contract kind of
appear. You do understand, as a TransStar
SPEAKER_00: employee, terrorist actions
will not be tolerated. You will not be able
SPEAKER_00: to assault or cause conflict
in the greater Soleimani nation.
SPEAKER_00: Understanding that every
employee is valuable to TransStar, your
SPEAKER_00: personal beliefs and disdain
of the Soleimani government must be kept
SPEAKER_00: privately into your mind, or
we will erase it for you. Be a TransStar
SPEAKER_00: employee today. And it's
basically saying, yeah, that's fine. We just
SPEAKER_00: need to know what type of bad
you were. Okay.
SPEAKER_02: Cool. All right.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Now the contracts
appear. Now, the contract
SPEAKER_00: is, they say, we start with an
open employment policy
SPEAKER_00: where for the next 30 days,
you have the full authority to leave your
SPEAKER_00: transtar as we have the full
authority to fire you. In 30 days, you will
SPEAKER_00: then make an agreement to stay
for either two, four, or
SPEAKER_00: six years as a term. And at
that time, you will no longer be able
SPEAKER_00: to Leave outside of your
personal off work hours.
SPEAKER_00: But we understand that being a
TransStar employee every day is not
SPEAKER_00: necessarily for everyone. And
that's why we have this waiting period
SPEAKER_00: where people can choose to
join TransStar or not.
SPEAKER_01: This is perfect for our needs.
Great. Yes. Wonderful.
SPEAKER_00: Now, You will be charged for
your housing, your food, your
SPEAKER_00: accumulation of space, and the
cleaning of your
SPEAKER_00: objects. All of these will be
SPEAKER_00: taken out of your salaries
before you receive them into your employee
SPEAKER_00: badge and credit cards. So she
starts handing employee badges off to
SPEAKER_00: you, and you see they have
your real faces.
SPEAKER_02: Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool,
cool. No doubt, no doubt.
SPEAKER_00: Because when you guys went in
the VR machines, they were able to do full
SPEAKER_00: body scans.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, yeah.
SPEAKER_00: We understand that you might
be hesitant to walk around with your
SPEAKER_00: previous identities, but
understand, as a TransStar employee, as long as
SPEAKER_00: you're in the TransStar
Exchange, you are immune to any aspect of
SPEAKER_00: Jordanian prosecution. And as
long as you're on a transtar ship, you
SPEAKER_00: also cannot be stopped by
Soleimani, Solsack, or any other member of
SPEAKER_00: the greater
SPEAKER_01: Soleimani Armed Forces. I
mean,
SPEAKER_01: that kind of works. Fantastic.
It's still corporate
SPEAKER_01: shill, but...
SPEAKER_00: Now, you've also been already
assigned housing blocks based on your
SPEAKER_00: particular test scores, but it
seems that you're all a
SPEAKER_00: cadre, would one say, right?
SPEAKER_01: What is that?
SPEAKER_00: Words of brothers and sisters.
SPEAKER_01: Well, yes.
SPEAKER_00: So, you all could attempt to
live in the executive location
SPEAKER_00: by your associate here. She is
in,
SPEAKER_00: she has a suite in floor 162.
SPEAKER_03: It in looks with the puppy dog
eyes of
SPEAKER_03: a corgi.
SPEAKER_00: By not using your assigned
locations, you will gain back 3% of your
SPEAKER_00: salary. Fuck yes! Holy shit!
SPEAKER_01: 3%? Marginal? I sleep on
floor! I start
SPEAKER_01: IRA.
SPEAKER_02: I do think we should ask our
boss if she's okay with that before we just
SPEAKER_02: say we're going to do that. I
look back with corgi puppy eyes. Yeah, I
SPEAKER_02: would appreciate keeping
everyone together. And how long do we work
SPEAKER_02: in our current position before
perhaps testing into a different role?
SPEAKER_02: Seeking promotion?
SPEAKER_00: Well, normally after you work
on a particular project, your supervisor
SPEAKER_00: can request for you to have a
promotion or be tested into another
SPEAKER_00: scenario.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, excellent, excellent,
excellent.
SPEAKER_00: Now, the project that we are
going to be having you work on is Aquatic
SPEAKER_00: Salvage.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Now, the reason one might
wonder why we need military-ized support is
SPEAKER_00: there is a rogue group of
dolphin extremists that are attempting to stop
SPEAKER_00: our salvage techniques, and
they need to be eliminated while our
SPEAKER_00: individual employees are
protected.
SPEAKER_01: Happy to help. And
SPEAKER_01: by eliminated, you mean just
SPEAKER_02: the threat neutralized and
they're set off somewhere else, right?
SPEAKER_00: Oh, if they're not causing a
problem, we don't care how that's solved.
SPEAKER_00: If you kill them, you kill
them. If you scare them off, you scare them
SPEAKER_00: off. As long as we are not
losing credits, we don't care.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Now, at the end of the 30
days, we will do a reassignment to a different
SPEAKER_00: group, but this project only
has about 60 days left in it, and that's
SPEAKER_00: why we thought it would be a
good place for you to be able to understand
SPEAKER_00: where the loaders can assist
the group, where we can have some military
SPEAKER_00: support, and those of you with
your spacecraft aspect will be piloting
SPEAKER_00: the submersible, which has a
very similar floor plan to a FAR trader
SPEAKER_00: just without the jump traps.
SPEAKER_01: All right. So I'm starting,
like, right now?
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, just stippling my
fingers and nodding my head. Yeah, just... Oh,
SPEAKER_00: no, no. We definitely want you
to make sure that you're able to
SPEAKER_00: experience tonight and bask in
the globe, now being a TransStar
SPEAKER_00: employee. You'll be starting
tomorrow at 4 a.m. Ooh!
SPEAKER_01: Do we get cool
SPEAKER_00: uniforms? Yes, you do get
TransStar uniforms.
SPEAKER_01: Awesome! We'll dance early!
SPEAKER_00: So... Owl!
SPEAKER_01: Are they color-coded unitards
or jumpsuits?
SPEAKER_00: They are going to be... Well,
except the military people, yes.
SPEAKER_00: Color-coded jumpsuits. Also,
you guys are going to have color-coded
SPEAKER_00: vac suits to go into the
water.
SPEAKER_01: But yes, you're like, you
know...
SPEAKER_00: Being a unified member of
Transtar at least keeps us off from being
SPEAKER_00: criminals of the state.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah. It gives us an
opportunity to buy back time. And be a
SPEAKER_02: corporate show.
SPEAKER_03: The question that has been on
Kiernan's mind, are we wrapping up?
SPEAKER_03: I don't know where we're at.
He'll ask this question in character as
SPEAKER_03: well. How long are we planning
to do this? Is this a career change? Are
SPEAKER_03: we just doing this until our
names are cleared? Have we just indentured
SPEAKER_03: ourselves?
SPEAKER_02: Well, we've definitely
indentured ourselves. It's just a matter of
SPEAKER_02: how...
SPEAKER_03: How long? So we have to clear
our names in 30 days now. It doesn't sound
SPEAKER_03: like we're indentured. Can't
we leave, didn't they say, in 30 days? For
SPEAKER_03: 30 days. Yeah, 30 days. If we
can't clear our names in 30 days, we're
SPEAKER_03: contracted for two years at
the minimum.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: I would like to also explain a
little of how we're going to run your
SPEAKER_00: TransStar employment time. So,
we are going to start it
SPEAKER_00: with, there is going to be one
key event each week of your employment,
SPEAKER_00: okay? Then, you guys have your
days off, okay? On your days off,
SPEAKER_00: you're obviously going to be
trying to clear your name. Yeah.
SPEAKER_02: This feels so episodic, like a
serial, like I'm a WB.
SPEAKER_00: I'm here for it. It's the
TransStar season. And
SPEAKER_00: as you guys basically learn
what's going on in the TransStar scenario,
SPEAKER_00: you're also going to gain
access and you're going to meet other
SPEAKER_00: TransStar employees and find
out about different ships that you guys
SPEAKER_00: might be able to have and the
like while you guys are trying to clear
SPEAKER_00: your name. But it's obviously
going to be harder to clear your name as a
SPEAKER_00: weekend side gig. But you're
at least safe. You don't have to
SPEAKER_00: worry about Veils. You don't
have to worry about whatever, your
SPEAKER_00: TransStar employees. People
can not just fuck with you for no reason.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah.
SPEAKER_03: Except their own people.
SPEAKER_00: And you guys will begin to see
the aftermath of the SoulSec guy getting
SPEAKER_00: the data that was sent to him,
because that was already done.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, because you guys were
freaking creepy and sent it to his house.
SPEAKER_02: Like, why would you do that?
Send the message. The other option was to
SPEAKER_02: have a drone delivered to him
in his car.
SPEAKER_01: Like, set the fire under his
head.
SPEAKER_02: At least that's not what,
like, people, like, you're gonna give them
SPEAKER_02: paranoia of suicide. Like, oh,
they're always watching me. I better not
SPEAKER_02: be here.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, you know, I mean, this
guy is hard-boiled. Yeah, he's the guy that
SPEAKER_03: usually does the watching.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, I want to circle back to
something. He said, no one can screw with
SPEAKER_00: us, except for the people
SPEAKER_03: who work here. They still got
to fill out requisition forms to fuck with
SPEAKER_03: us, right? So it's not as bad
as that's your...
SPEAKER_00: So, did people enjoy tonight's
TransDar game? Yes.
SPEAKER_00: Most definitely.
SPEAKER_02: Where are we going to put
Carla? Is she going to do the tests too?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, I'm just going to have
her do the military test because she's
SPEAKER_00: likely to win the military
test. Okay, cool. Because if I give her
SPEAKER_00: three choices on that in
escalating things, I easily can imagine her
SPEAKER_00: getting to two or three. Okay.
And then we'll see if she loses.
SPEAKER_00: After missions, we can try
advancing again? No, no, no.
SPEAKER_00: After... Like, the C thing is
done. Then they'll put you in... Your
SPEAKER_00: boss can recommend you for
another test.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: So, unless you guys want to be
Transstar for the Chronicle, or ditch
SPEAKER_00: your guys' contract halfway
through, no one's getting a new test.
SPEAKER_03: Okay. Kiernan's not lottery.
He's ready to leave already. Yeah. Mm-hmm.
SPEAKER_03: And...
SPEAKER_00: Obviously, once you guys get
your identities back or you find the
SPEAKER_00: criminals or whatever, and
Transtar also has records and stuff.
SPEAKER_00: Obviously, people ought to be
shipping stuff back and forth. Also, you
SPEAKER_00: can, let's say you guys do
choose to give up. You could just, now that
SPEAKER_00: you're Transtar employees, you
could just save all your income from
SPEAKER_00: Transtar to quit at 30 days
and pay for a flight off.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, okay.
SPEAKER_00: That works. And then you're
still enemies of the Soleimani State, but at
SPEAKER_00: least you're not here. So
there are a few kind of
SPEAKER_00: avenues and angles you guys
can go. But the transfer was
SPEAKER_00: always meant to be basic. It's
the net. Like, you guys could have kept
SPEAKER_00: running around without veils.
You guys could have... Gone super
SPEAKER_00: criminal. You guys could have
done a lot of kind of angles. The
SPEAKER_00: TransStar one is no matter
what, you guys were going to hit that net if
SPEAKER_00: you had no other choices.
SPEAKER_01: Thank you.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I mean, we just all seem
very, well, I don't want to say all. The
SPEAKER_02: majority seem very against
working with a mobster, and I count myself as
SPEAKER_02: one of those. Because, again,
I just felt like trying to clear our
SPEAKER_02: names, but then having done
terrible things was counterproductive.
SPEAKER_03: If we don't get caught, then
we never did a crime.
SPEAKER_00: In Germany, it's not against
the law to try to break out a prison.
SPEAKER_02: That's true. That's very true.
SPEAKER_00: But did people have fun? Yeah.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, absolutely. I mean, I
wish I had rolled higher than a three on
SPEAKER_02: my... I was only going to try
two rolls, so...
SPEAKER_03: If I had gone to the other
test, I may have done very well on it,
SPEAKER_03: actually. What would have been
SPEAKER_01: the fourth one? For the space.
For
SPEAKER_01: space, let me pull up the
sheet.
SPEAKER_01: Wait, no.
SPEAKER_00: So the space one, all the
seats were there. It was leadership. Yes, you
SPEAKER_00: did the fourth role.
SPEAKER_03: You failed on the fourth one,
didn't you? I failed on the fourth one.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, so you did all four.
Right. The fifth is you actually did
SPEAKER_00: leadership, too.
SPEAKER_01: That would be the captain's
chair.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, it's captain, it's
pilot, it's basically electronics, and it's
SPEAKER_00: engineering. Those are the
five seats.
SPEAKER_03: I could have done each and
every one of those roles. It's all sad.
SPEAKER_02: What would have been the next
for the combat?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, what's the third combat
been? The next for combat... Let me pull
SPEAKER_00: it up. So the next for combat
was going to be
SPEAKER_00: athletics strength. It was
going to be
SPEAKER_00: a drive, and I was going to
roll random on a drive. It was going to
SPEAKER_00: be... Vax
SPEAKER_00: suit, and it was going to be a
gun combat slug.
SPEAKER_02: Gun combat slug would have
been good for me, but... I might have been
SPEAKER_02: able to go
SPEAKER_03: Vax suit, but with the
variant, okay.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, but hey. You roll Vax
suits also on battle suits, that's why it
SPEAKER_00: starts there.
SPEAKER_01: Yes. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. But yeah, and then the
like
SPEAKER_00: last ones of that was like I
tried to make each one of the tests also
SPEAKER_00: different. So it wasn't like
the fact
SPEAKER_00: that the the space when you
got to pick your seat and the executive one,
SPEAKER_00: it was an unknown every time.
And then the combat one, it was a combat
SPEAKER_00: team. It was tried to give
each one a different vibe.
SPEAKER_00: It was pretty cool. I like it.
Okay. So I'm happy to let people go, and
SPEAKER_00: we can do in two weeks, and I
will start writing more TransStar stuff,
SPEAKER_00: because I have, like, one
page.
SPEAKER_02: I thought it was a secret
place that we could go hide out. I didn't
SPEAKER_02: necessarily think it was going
to be a three-day pass to Disney World.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, you guys also didn't
need to take the test.
SPEAKER_00: You guys could have just,
like, slept in the streets with
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I suppose.
SPEAKER_03: We could have just said
purchasing or something
SPEAKER_00: like that. This is solving
problems. We've solved some problems. Yeah,
SPEAKER_00: exactly.
SPEAKER_02: The recruitment video was too
good. Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Corporate estimates. I want to
be a part of the team. I
SPEAKER_00: actually have some television
commercials already prepped when you guys
SPEAKER_00: are, like, watching TV. Join
me. I'll do my part.
SPEAKER_00: There's going to be one about
how one kid was
SPEAKER_00: pulled out for being special
and that he was able to do all these
SPEAKER_00: particular things and we need
to understand that every single person in
SPEAKER_00: the Salmon Nation is
important. And then there's going to be another one
SPEAKER_00: about, oh, you know, through a
shipping accident, this man lost his wife
SPEAKER_00: and And he lost his brother.
But
SPEAKER_00: now he's given us support by
the Solomani Nation and we've
SPEAKER_00: given him free housing and all
these other things because you're part of
SPEAKER_00: the Solomani family. And I've
like, I think, 10 commercials
SPEAKER_00: written up. Wow.
SPEAKER_02: You're prepared for our
hijinks.
SPEAKER_00: Hijinks. You guys went
corporate chill at least for 30 days. Or you guys
SPEAKER_00: can leave tomorrow. By the
way, you guys can just leave in three days,
SPEAKER_00: too. It's you have any time
within 30 days to leave. Right.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: No, there's definitely a... As
soon as we clear our names, we can go.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah. Like, hell, you guys
could just not show up to work and wait for
SPEAKER_00: them to, like, fire you. Yeah.
SPEAKER_02: Well, my thought was, oh, we
do the submarine mission until we get
SPEAKER_02: the... I'm assuming this is
related to the rumors we heard of the ship
SPEAKER_02: being sunk in waters. So we,
you know, I kind of want to just sub until
SPEAKER_02: we can get the ship out and
steal the ship. But then we're now stuck in
SPEAKER_02: a ship that Transstar would
then be after, so...
SPEAKER_00: It's a little different than
you think. It's basically... Mike, not to
SPEAKER_00: give all of it away, Transtar
is involved in something in the water, but
SPEAKER_00: because you have an executive
there, she can keep pushing resources to
SPEAKER_00: get you guys also working on
the ship while she's trying to cover up you
SPEAKER_00: guys are doing the Transtar
project.
SPEAKER_01: Oh.
SPEAKER_00: And when aren't guards or
escorting loaders carrying stuff around, who's
SPEAKER_00: going to ask a lot of
questions? And the fact that you guys
SPEAKER_00: also have so many loaders, no
one's going to think that you guys are
SPEAKER_00: doing anything hijink. You're
like, we were told to load this to here.
SPEAKER_00: That's what the paperwork
says. And we have an
SPEAKER_00: exact that can make the
paperwork look real. And those security guys
SPEAKER_00: already cleared it. What are
you guys complaining about? Right. And I do
SPEAKER_00: think that, like, Annette
being, like, the guard of the executive, like,
SPEAKER_00: who's gonna fuck with her?
Because she gets... By the way, you can just
SPEAKER_00: take out her restrainer bolt
now. So, like, anybody who wants to fuck
SPEAKER_00: with you can be like...
SPEAKER_02: Yay, guns!
SPEAKER_00: It's, uh... Oh, and by the
way, the vibe of Transtar is supposed to be,
SPEAKER_00: like, CCP from RoboCop.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, okay. Okay. I got a very
Disney vibe from them, but I think that's
SPEAKER_02: the whole, like, have a
magical day kind of bullshit.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, I tried to make it a
little between, like, CCP and Boeing.
SPEAKER_00: That's the Disney feel you're
getting.
SPEAKER_02: I guess that is a Disney.
Boeing is very corporate. Yeah. Happy, yeah.
SPEAKER_02: Boeing is mother, Boeing is
father.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. I'm going to let you go.
I'm going to kill the recording, and I
SPEAKER_00: will see you all in two weeks.
SPEAKER_01: All right. Thank you, guys.
Good night. Good night.